so
you're talking about the symmetries in
data could these analogies also be
represented using the kind of symmetries
that you were talking about
good question what do you think of it a
bit um
modern machine learning operates with
large high quality data sets
which together with appropriate
computational resources motivates the
design of rich function spaces with the
capacity to interpolate over the data
points
now this mindset plays well with neural
networks since even the simplest choices
of inductive prior yield a dense class
of functions
now symmetry as wide or narrow as you
may define its meaning is one idea by
which man through the ages has tried to
comprehend and create order
beauty
and perfection
and that was a quote from hermann vile a
german mathematician
who was born in the 19th century
now since the early days researchers
have adapted neural networks to exploit
the low dimensional geometry arising
from physical measurements for example
grids in images
sequences in time series or position and
momentum in molecules and their
associated symmetries such as
translation or rotation
now folks this is an epic special
edition of mlst we've been working on
this since may of this year so please
use the table of contents on youtube if
you want to skip around the show is
about three and a half hours long the
second half of the show roughly speaking
is a traditional style mlst episode but
the beginning part is a bit of an
experiment for us maybe a bit of a
departure we want to make some netflix
style content and we've even been
filming on location with our guests so i
hope you enjoy the show and let us know
what you think in the youtube comments
many people intuit that there are some
deep theoretical links between some of
the recent deep learning model
architectures particularly the ones on
sets actually and this may be why so
many popular architectures keep getting
reinvented
now the other day fabian fuchs from
oxford university released a really cool
blog post about deep learning on sets
elucidating a math heavy paper that he
co-authored with edward wagstaff
now he wanted to understand why so many
neural network architectures for sets um
resemble either deep sets
or self-attention
because sets come in any ordering
there are many opportunities to design
inductive priors to capture the
symmetries
so raises the question
how do we design deep learning
algorithms that are invariant to
semantically equivalent transformations
while maintaining maximum expressivity
now fabian pointed out that the
so-called genoci pooling framework gives
a satisfying explanation genocide
pooling is when you generate all of the
k-tuples of a set an average over your
target function on those permutations
it gives you a computationally tractable
way of achieving permutation in variance
so rather than computing n factorial
combinations of the examples you compute
n factorial divided by n minus k
factorial which for small k is very
tractable now clearly setting k to n
gives you the most expressive yet the
most expensive model
but that would be cool it would model
the high order interactions between the
examples but it turns out that deep sets
are this configuration with k equals one
and self-attention is this configuration
with k equals two
now fabian also spoke about approximate
permutation and variance
which is when you set k to n
the number of examples but you sample
the permutations turns out you don't
have to sample very many of them to get
good results but anyway if you want to
check out that in a little bit more
detail go and check out fabian's blog
i've put a link in the video description
high dimensional learning is impossible
due to the curse of dimensionality it
only works if we make some very strong
assumptions about the regularities of
the space of functions that we need to
search through
now the classical assumptions that we
make in machine learning are no longer
relevant
now in general learning in high
dimensions is intractable
the number of samples grows
exponentially with the number of
dimensions the universal function
approximation theorem popularized in the
1990s states that for the class of
shallow neural network functions you can
approximate any continuous function to
arbitrary precision by just stacking the
neurons right assuming that you had
enough of them
so it's a bit like kind of sparse coding
if you like
the curse of dimensionality refers to
the various phenomena that arise when
analyzing and organizing data in high
dimensional spaces that do not occur in
low dimensional settings such as the
three dimensional physical space of
everyday experience
now the common theme of these problems
is that when the dimensionality
increases the volume of the space
increases so fast that the available
data effectively becomes sparse this
sparsity is problematic for any method
that requires statistical significance
now in order to obtain a statistically
sound and reliable result the amount of
data needed to support the result often
grows exponentially with the
dimensionality
most of the information in data has
regularities now what this means in
plain english is just like on a
kaleidoscope most of the information
which has been generated by the physical
world is actually redundant just many
repeated semantically equivalent
replicas of the same thing the world
is full of simulacrums
machine learning algorithms need to
encode the appropriate notion of
regularity to cut down the search space
of possible functions you might have
heard this idea referred to as an
inductive bias
now machine learning is about trading
off these three sources of error
statistical error from approximating the
expectations on a finite sample and this
grows as you increase your hypothesis
space
approximation error which is how good is
your model in that hypothesis space if
your function space is too small then
the one that you find will incur a lot
of approximation error and finally
optimization error which is the ability
to find a global optimum
now even if we make strong assumptions
about our hypothesis space you know it's
just to say that it should be lip shits
or in plain english it should be locally
smooth
it's still way too large we want to have
a way to search through the space to get
anywhere so the statistical error is
cursed by the dimensionality if we make
the hypothesis or the function space
really small then the search space is
smaller but the approximation error is
cursed by dimensionality
so we need to define better function
spaces to search through
but how
we need to move towards a new class of
function spaces which is to say
geometrically inspired function spaces
let's exploit the underlying low
dimensional structure of the high
dimensional input space the geometric
domain can give us entirely new notions
of regularity which we can exploit
now using geometrical priors which is to
say only allowing equivariant functions
or ones which respect a particular
geometrical principle this will reduce
the space of possible functions that we
search through which means less risk of
statistical error and less risk of
overfitting we should be able to do this
without increasing approximation error
because we should know for sure that the
true function has a certain geometrical
property which will bias into the model
so introducing the geometrical deep
learning proto book so recently
professor michael bronstein professor
joanne bruna dr tako cohen and dr peta
velizkovic released an epic proto book
called geometric deep learning
grids groups graphs geodesics and gauges
these researchers are elegantly linking
classical theory and machine learning in
geometry and group theory to deep
learning which is fascinating
now the proto book is beautifully
written right it's presented so well it
even has some helpful margin notes and
honestly i could read sections of it out
loud on mlst with scant need to change a
single word it's that well written i
mean it is there's a lot of maths in
there as well let's be honest we can't
can't dodge that but um i often try to
impress upon people that if your writing
sounds weird when you say it out loud
then you're probably writing it the
wrong way but these guys have written it
really well
now they've essentially created an
abstraction or a blueprint as they call
it which prototypically describes all of
the deep learning architectures the
geometrical prize that they have
described so far they don't prescribe a
specific architecture but rather a
series of necessary conditions the book
provides a mathematical framework to
study this field and it's essentially a
mindset on you know how to build new
architectures it gives constructive
you know procedures to incorporate prior
physical knowledge into neural
architectures and it provides a
principled way to build future
architectures which have not yet been
invented
the researchers have also recently
released a series of 12 brilliant
lectures on all of the material in the
book and i've linked these in the video
description
now what are the core domains of
geometric deep learning so in geometric
deep learning the data lives on a domain
this domain is a set
it might have additional structure like
a neighborhood in a graph or it might
have a metric such as you know what's
the distance between two points in the
set but most of the time the data isn't
the domain itself it's a representation
or it's a signal which is on a hillbit
space
let's talk about symmetries symmetries
are really important to understand this
framework so
a symmetry of an object is simply a
transformation of that object which
leaves it unchanged
now there are many different types of
symmetries and deep learning i mean for
example there are symmetries of the
weights if you take two neurons in a
neural network and you swap them the
neural network is still graph isomorphic
there are symmetries of the label
function which means that an image is
still a dog even if you apply a rotation
transformation to it um actually if we
knew all of the symmetries of a certain
class we would only need one labeled
example right because we would recognize
any other examples that you give it as
kind of semantically equivalent
transformations but we can't do that
right because the learning problem is
difficult which means we don't actually
know all of the symmetries in advance
now in the context of geometric deep
learning we talk about symmetries of the
core structured geometric domains that
we're interested in so
grids or graphs for example a symmetry
is any transformation which preserves
the structure of the geometric domain
that the signal lives on so for example
permutations of a set preserves the set
membership or euclidean transformations
like rotations or reflections preserved
distances and angles
there are a few rules to remember
because uh the way we deal with this
paradigm is we talk about how composable
those symmetries are the identity
transformation is always a symmetry
composing a symmetry transformation is
always a symmetry the inverse of a
symmetry is always a symmetry we can
formulate this with this mathematically
abstract notion of a group group theory
in mathematics is fascinating because it
concerns only with how elements compose
with each other not what they actually
are so different kinds of objects may
have the same symmetry group for example
the group of rotational and reflection
symmetries of a triangle is the same as
the group of permutations of sequences
of three elements
so let's talk about the blueprint itself
the blueprint has three core principles
symmetry
scale separation and geometric stability
in machine learning multi-scale
representations and local invariants are
the fundamental mathematical principles
underpinning the efficiency of
convolutional neural networks and graph
neural networks they are typically
implemented in the form of local pooling
in some sense now these principles give
us a very general blueprint of geometric
deep learning that can be recognized in
the majority of popular deep neural
network architectures a typical design
consists of a sequence of locally
equivariate layers i mean think of the
convolution layers in a cnn
then a pooling or a coarsening layer so
you recognize those in cnn's as well and
finally followed by a globally invariant
pooling layer so that might be your
classification head now these building
blocks provide a rich approximation
space which have prescribed invariance
and stability properties by combining
them together into a scheme that these
researchers refer to as the geometric
deep learning blueprint
now the research has also introduced the
concept of geometric stability which
extends the notion of group invariants
and equivariance to approximate symmetry
or transformations around the group they
quantify this in some sense by looking
at a metric space between the
transformations themselves
this is professor michael bronstein
the problem is that traditional machine
learning techniques
work well with images or audio
but they are not designed to deal with
network structured data in order to
address this challenge we've developed a
new framework
that we call geometric deep learning
it allowed us to
learn the network effects of clinically
approved drugs
and to predict
anti-cancer drug-like properties of
other molecules
for example
molecules contained in food
neural networks have exploded leading to
several success stories in industrial
applications and i think it's quite
indicative that last year two major
biological journals featured geometric
depending papers on their cover which
means that it has already become
mainstream and possibly will lead to new
exciting results in fundamental sciences
the book i hold is called the road to
reality it's written by a british
mathematician and recent nobel laureate
project penrose a professor at oxford
and it's really probably one of the most
complete attempts to to write and
describe modern physics in its
mathematical underpinning
and you can see it's very heavy but if i
were to compress the the thousand plus
pages of this book into just a single
concept
i can capture it in one word and this is
symmetry
and symmetry is really a fundamental
concept and fundamental idea that
underpins
all modern physics as we know it so the
for example the
the standard model of particle physics
can entirely be derived
from the considerations of symmetry and
that's the kind of idea that we try to
use
in deep learning to derive and create
new neural network architectures
entirely from fundamental concepts and
fundamental principles of symmetry
in the past decade deep learning has
brought a revolution in data science and
made possible many tasks previously
thought to be beyond reach
on the other hand we now have a zoo of
different neural network architectures
for different types of data but few
unifying principles
the authors also point out that
different geometric deep learning
methods differ in their choice of domain
or symmetry group or the implementation
specific details of those building
blocks that we spoke about but many of
the deep learning architectures
currently in use fall into this scheme
and can thus be derived from common
geometrical principles
as a consequence it is difficult to
understand the relations between
different methods which inevitably leads
to the reinvention and rebranding of the
same concepts
so we need some form of geometric
unification in the spirit of the
erlangen program that i call geometric
learning it serves two purposes first to
provide a common mathematical framework
to derive the most successful neural
network architectures
and second to give a constructive
procedure to build future architectures
in a principled way this is a very
general design that can be applied to
different types of geometric structures
such as grids homogeneous spaces with
global transformation groups graphs and
many folds where we have global isometry
in variants as well as local gauge
symmetries
we call these the 5g of geometric deep
learning the implementation of these
principles leads to some of the most
popular architectures that exist today
in deep learning such as convolutional
networks emerging from translational
symmetry craft neural networks deep sets
and transformers implementing
permutation environments and intrinsic
mesh cnns used in computer graphics and
vision that can be derived from gauge
symmetries
people are quite cynical about the
interpolative nature of deep learning
and i think that finding this structure
this this
deeper structure could allow us to
extrapolate in a way which is
significantly better than we can now
and i asked whether he thought deep
learning could get us all the way to
artificial general intelligence it's a
hard question because it has several
terms that are not well defined what do
you define by intelligence so we don't
understand what is human intelligence
everybody probably gives a different
meaning to this term so it's hard for me
to even to define and quantify
artificial intelligence i don't think
that we necessarily need to emulate
human intelligence and as you mentioned
in the past we thought of
artificial intelligence as being able to
to solve certain tasks and it's a kind
of a moving target we thought of i don't
know playing intelligent games or uh
perception of the visual world like
computer vision or understanding and
translating language or even creativity
and today we have
machine learning systems that are able
to to address at least to some extent
all of these
tasks sometimes even better than humans
and are we there yet
at artificial intelligence i don't think
so
and probably artificial intelligence
will look differently from human
intelligence it doesn't need to look
like human intelligence it's of course
an interesting scientific question
whether we can reproduce a human in
silico but uh for solving practical
problems
that will make this technology useful
for the humanity for the human kind
we probably need something different it
will certainly involve certain level of
abstraction that we currently don't have
it will probably require methods that we
currently don't have
but it doesn't necessarily need to look
like a recreation of a human
this is dr peta velichkovic
by now you'll have probably seen or
heard something about our recently
released proto book on geometric deep
learning on grids graphs groups
geodesics engages or as we like to call
it the 5gs of geometric deep learning
which i've co-authored alongside michael
bronstein john bruna and taco cohen
and you might be wondering what all the
fuss is about because there's already a
lot of really high quality synthesis
textbooks on the field of deep learning
in general and also on some sub areas of
geometric deep learning such as graph
neural networks where will hamilton
recently released a super high quality
textbook on that area this is dr taco
cohen
so what we've been trying to do in our
book project
is to show that this geometric deep
learning mindset is not just useful when
tackling a new problem but actually
allows you to derive from first
principles of symmetry and skill
separation
many of the uh architectures and
architectural primitives like
convolution attention graph convolution
and so forth
that have become popular uh over the
last uh a few years
even in cases where these considerations
vector variants and skill separation
were not front and center when the
methods were first discovered
now we think that this
is useful for a number of reasons first
of all it might help to
avoid reinventing the same ideas over
and over and this can easily happen when
the number of papers that come out every
day is this far
larger than what any one person can can
possibly
impossibly read
and when different subfields
use different language to describe their
their ideas
furthermore it might help to clarify
when a particular method is useful a
geometric deep learning method is useful
when the problem domain has the
particular symmetries that are built
into the to the architecture
and finally we hope that that
by
making explicit the commonalities
between seemingly different methods it
will become easier for new cars to learn
geometric deep learning
ideally one would not have to go through
the large
number of architectures that have been
designed but just learn the general
ideas of uh groups equivariance
group representations and feature spaces
and so on and then see for the
particular instances you're interested
in
how that fits into the general pattern
to really
illustrate why do we think that such a
synthesis is important and relevant for
deep learning research going forward we
have to go way back way back in the time
of euclid around 300 years bc
and as you might know euclid is the
founding father of euclidean geometry
which for many many years was the only
way to do geometry it relied on a
certain set of postulates that euclid
had that governed all the laws of the
geometry that he proposed
all of this started to drastically
change around the 1800s when several
mathematicians in an effort to prove
that euclid's geometry is the geometry
to be following ended up assuming that
one of the postulates is false and
failing to drive a contradiction they
actually ended up deriving a completely
new set of self-consistent geometries
all with their own set of laws and rules
and also quite differing terminologies
among some of these popular variants are
the hyperbolic geometry of lobochevsky
and bulgari and the elliptic geometries
of riemann and for a very long time
because all of these geometries had
completely different sets of rules and
they were all self-consistent people
were generally wondering what is the one
true geometry that we should be studying
a solution to this problem came several
decades later through the work of a
young
german mathematician by the name of
felix klein who had just been appointed
for a professorship position at the
small bavarian university of
erlangen the so-called friedrich
alexander university in erlang and
nuremberg
while he was at this post he had
proposed a
direction that would eventually enable
us to unify all of the geometries that
were in existence at the time
through the lens of invariances in
symmetry using the language of group
theory and his work is now eponymously
known as the erlangen program and
it there is no way to overstate how much
of an important effect the erlangen
program had on mathematics and beyond
because of the fact that it provided a
unifying lens of studying geometry
suddenly people didn't need to hunt for
the one true geometry they had a
blueprint they could use to drive
whatever geometry was necessary for the
problem they were solving and besides
just mathematics it had amazing
spillover effects to other very
important fields of science for example
in physics the erlangen program spilled
over through the work of emmy nother
demonstrated that all of the
conservation laws in physics which
previously had to be validated through
extensive experimental evaluation could
be completely derivable through the
principles of symmetry and needless to
say this is a very fundamental and
game-changing result in physics which
also allowed us to classify some
elementary particles in what is now
known as the standard model thinking
back towards theoretical computer
science
the erlangen program also had a
spillover effect into category theory
which is one of the most abstractified
areas of theoretical computer science
with a lot of potential for unifying
various directions in mathematics and
actually in the words of the founders of
category theory the whole field of
category theory can be seen as an
extension of felix science erlangen
program
so
the erlangen program demonstrated how
it's possible to take a small set of
guiding principles of invariance in
symmetry and use it to unify something
as broad as geometry i like to think of
geometric depending as not a single
method or architecture but as a mindset
it's a way of looking at machine
learning problems from the first
principles of symmetry and environments
and symmetry is a key idea that
underpins our physical world and the
data that is created by physical
processes and accounting for this
structure allows us to beat the curse of
dimensionality in machine learning
problems
it is really a very powerful principle
and very generic blueprint and we find
its instances in some of today's most
popular deep learning architectures
whether it's convolutional neural
networks graph neural networks
transformers lstms and many more
and it is also a way to design new
machine learning architectures that are
yet to be invented maybe in the future
not based on back propagation and
incorporate inductive bias in a
principled way being a professor and a
teacher i would also like to emphasize
the pedagogical dimension of this
geometric unification
what i often see in deep learning when
deep learning is taught is that it's it
appears as a bunch of hacks with weak or
non-justification and i think
it is best illustrated with how for
example the concept of convolution is
explained it is often given as a formula
just out of the blue maybe with a bit of
hand waving
but what we try to show is that you can
derive convolution from first principles
in this particular case of translational
symmetry and i think the difference in
this approach is best captured by what
el vezos once said that the knowledge of
principles easily compensates the lack
of knowledge of facts
professor bronstein has been a professor
at imperial college in london for the
last three years and received his phd
with distinction from technion the
israeli institute of technology in two
thousand seven he's held visiting
academic positions at mit
harvard and stanford and his work has
been cited over 21 000 times
his main expertise is in theoretical and
computational geometric methods for
machine learning and data science and
his research encompasses a broad
spectrum of applications ranging from
computer vision and pattern recognition
to geometry processing computer graphics
and biomedicine
professor bronstein coined and
popularized the term geometric deep
learning
his startup company fabula ai which was
acquired by twitter in 2019
was one of the first applications of
graph ml to the problem of
misinformation detection i think it's no
exaggeration to say that professor
bronstein is the world's most
recognizable expert in graph
representation learning research
we are really in
probably some of the the nicest
locations in london
which is kensington if you're familiar
so we have the the natural history
museum the science museum
and the victoria and albert museum and
imperial colleges
right here
so
i think it's as central as you can get
and if you walk
all the way there then you have hyde
park which is probably one of the nicest
parks in london i'm a professor in the
department of competing at imperial
college london
and head of graph learning research at
twitter
i work on geometric deep learning in
particular on graph neural networks and
their applications from computer vision
and graphics to computational biology
and drug design
dr petter velichkovic is a senior
research scientist at deepmind in london
and he obtained his phd from trinity
college in cambridge
his research has been focused on
geometric deep learning and in
particular devising neural network
architectures for graph representation
learning and its applications in
algorithmic reasoning and computational
biology
pettar's work has been published in the
leading machine learning venues peter
was the first author of graph attention
networks a popular convolutional layer
for graphs and deep graph infomax a
scalable unsupervised learning pipeline
for graphs
hi everyone my name is peter velichkovic
and i'm a senior research scientist at
deepmind and previously i have done my
phd in computer science at the
university of cambridge where i'm
actually still based and today we're
actually here in cambridge filming these
shots
and it is my great pleasure to be
talking to you today about our work on
geometric deep learning and
related topics
i first got into computer science
through competitive programming contests
and classical algorithms the likes of
which you might find in a traditional
theoretical computer science textbook
and this was primarily influenced by the
way schooling worked for gifted students
back in my hometown of belgrade in
serbia where students were generally
encouraged to take part in these
theoretical contests and try to write
programs that are just going to finish
as fast as possible or work as
efficiently as possible over
a certain set of carefully contrived
problems
all of this changed when i actually
started my computer science degree here
at cambridge where i was suddenly
exposed to a much wider wealth of
computer science topics than just
theoretical computer science and
algorithms and for a brief moment my
interests drifted elsewhere
everything started to come back together
when i started
my final year project with professor
pietro leo at cambridge and
i had heard that bioinformatics is a
topic that's brimming with classical
algorithms and competitive programming
algorithms specifically so i thought a
project in this area would be a great
way to bring these two closer to
unfortunately that was not to be as my
mentor very quickly drew me into machine
learning and
that kind of spiraled out into my phd
topics
where i was
for a brief moment focused on
computational biology topics before
eventually drifting to
graph representation learning and
eventually geometric deep learning my
journey into geometric deep learning
started actually through
investigating
graph representation learning which i
think for a very long time these two
areas have been seen as almost
synonymous with one another because
almost everything you come up with in
the area of geometric deep learning can
be if you squint hard enough seen as a
special case of graph representation
learning what originally brought me into
this was an internship at montreal's
artificial intelligence institute miele
where i worked alongside joshua bengio
and adriana romero on
initially methodologies for
processing data that lives on meshes of
the human brain
we found out that the existing proposals
for processing data over such a mesh
both in graph neural networks and
otherwise were not the most adequate for
the kind of data processing that we
needed to do and we needed something
that would be aligned more with image
convolutions in spirit in a way that
allows us to give different influences
to different neighbors in the mesh and
this led us to propose graph attention
networks
which was a paper that we published at
iclear 2018 it was actually my first
top-tier conference publication
and
what i'm probably most well known for
nowadays the field of graph
representation learning has then
spiraled completely out of control in
terms of the quantity of papers being
proposed
only one year after the graph retention
network paper came out i was reviewing
for some of the conferences in the area
and i
found on my reviewing stack four or five
papers that were extending graph
attention nets in one way or another so
the field certainly has become a lot
more vibrant because of a nice
barrier of entry which is not too high
recently petta has been doing some
really
interesting research in algorithmic
reasoning
part of the skill of a software engineer
lies in choosing which algorithm to use
only rarely will an entirely novel
algorithm be warranted the key guarantee
which traditional symbolic algorithms
give us is generalization to new
situations
traditional algorithms and the
predictions given by deep learning
models have very different properties
the former provides strong guarantees
but are inflexible to the problem being
tackled while the latter provide few
guarantees but can adapt to a wide range
of problems now petta in his paper
proposed a neural architecture which can
take in natural inputs but output a
graph of abstract outputs as well as
natural outputs pettar believes that
neural algorithmic reasoning will allow
us to apply classical algorithms on
inputs that they were never originally
designed for i am studying algorithmic
reasoning which
is a novel area of representation
learning that seeks to find neural
networks that
are as good as possible at imitating the
computations of exactly the kind of
classical algorithms that initially
brought me to computer science it turns
out that this area is remarkably rich
and could have remarkably big
implications for
machine learning in general because it
could bring the best of the algorithmic
domain
into the
domain of neural networks and if you
look at the pros and cons of the two
you'll find that they're very
complementary so the fusion of the two
can really bring the kinds of benefits
we haven't seen before so
i am very pleased to say that
i'm among those researchers that is
extremely proud and happy of what i do
because it brings together some of my
earliest passions in computer science
with the latest trends in machine
learning especially geometric deep
learning which we recently released a
proto book about with
john michael and taco we spoke to
christian sagetti and he's doing some
interesting work with
algorithmic reasoning creating
abstract syntax trees to represent uh
mathematical theorems for example and
then he believes that in that
representation space he projects it all
into euclidean space that there's some
interesting interpretative points in
that space but
again surely there must be some deeper
structure which analogizes mathematics
which would allow us to extrapolate and
discover new interesting mathematics it
just feels that what we're missing is
the right kind of structure i think for
mathematics it's relatively easy to
formalize it because well we can write
logic rules and basically we can build
mathematics axiomatically from very
basic principles these matters are
already being used for computer proof of
certain theorems i think it's not well
regarded by the purists and pure
mathematics but probably they will need
to accept it and well you know maybe
there will be a field medal that will be
given for a proof that is done by a
computer i think
even recently there are some important
breakthrough results
proofs that were given by a computer
so it is probably just the beginning of
a new way of doing science essentially
even as pure science as creative
sciences mathematics which was
considered really the hallmark of human
intelligence it can be maybe if not
replaced assisted by by artificial
intelligence
peter invokes daniel kahneman's system 1
and system 2. he thinks that we need
something like system 2 to achieve the
kind of reasoning and generalization
which currently eludes us
in deep learning models
what i'm holding in my hands right now
is the international bestseller on
thinking fast and slow from the famous
nobel prize winner daniel conman
this book can be seen as one of the main
theses behind my ongoing work in
algorithmic reasoning and what it stands
for because it argues that fundamentally
we as humans employ two different
systems that operate at different rates
system one which primarily deals with
perceptive tasks and system two which
deals with longer range reasoning tasks
and it is my belief that currently where
our research in neural networks has
taken us is to get really really good at
automating away system one so being able
to perform
perceptive tasks from large quantities
of observed data
probably in a in a not too dissimilar
manner from the way humans do it what i
feel is really missing from these
architectures nowadays is the system two
aspects being able to actually take
these percepts that we've acquired from
the environment and actually properly do
rigid reasoning over them in a manner
that will stay consistent even if we
drastically change the number of objects
slightly perturbed the laws of physics
or something like that in my opinion
algorithmic reasoning the art of
capturing these kinds of reasoning
computations inside a neural network
that was trained specifically for that
purpose and then slotting that neural
network into a different architecture
that works with raw percepts is one
potentially very promising blueprint
that will take the space of classical
algorithms that we have been building in
this system two space and carry them
over into raw perceptive inputs which
these algorithms were very rarely
designed to work over this is dr taco
cohen
hello
i'm taco kong i'm a researcher at coco
ai research and i work on geometric deep
learning equivalent networks and more
recently also on causal inference and
causal representation learning
now i've been interested for a number of
years already since about 2013 in the
application of ideas around symmetry
invariance equivariance in the
underlying mathematics of group theory
and group representation theory to
machine learning and deep learning
specifically
and so it's been quite exciting to see
over the last few years really the
blossoming of this field that we now
call geometric deep learning
many new methods such as various kinds
of equivariant convolutions for
different spaces different groups of
symmetries different geometric feature
types aquivariate transformers and
attention mechanisms point cloud
networks graph and real networks and so
forth
and along with these new methods also a
large number of
applications that have been tackled
anything from medical imaging to the
analysis of global weather and climate
data to the analysis of dna sequences
and proteins and other kinds of
of molecules so if you apply this
mindset the first question you ask when
faced with such a new problem is what
are the symmetries what are the
transformations that i can apply to my
data that may change the numerical
representation of my data as stored in
my computer but that nevertheless don't
change the underlying object we're
interested in whether that's reordering
the nodes of a graph
rotating a molecule in
3d or many other kinds of symmetries
once you know the group of symmetries
you can then develop a neural network
that's aquivariate symmetries
and hopefully
is a universal approximator among
acquivariate functions
what we've found what many others have
found time and again
is that if you
build this symmetry prior to your
network if you make your network
equivalent it is bound to be much more
data efficient and to generalize much
better
uh hey tim great to be here uh so um
so yeah the blueprint so
what we uh what we realized uh as we
were writing this this book is that
really a lot of different architectures
they can be understood in one as
essentially as special cases of one
generic structure that we call the
geometric deep learning blueprint
so to explain a little bit about what
this is all about the the uh the
blueprint
refers to first of all feature spaces so
i'll explain how we model those
and then it refers to maps between
feature spaces or layers of the of the
network and else they have to somehow
respect the structure
of the feature spaces
so in all cases whether it's you know
graph neural net a network for
processing images on the plane
or a network for processing signals on a
home sphere like global weather data
we're dealing with data that lives on a
domain so the domain in the examples i
just gave would be the set of nodes on
the graph of the graph or perhaps also
the set of edges
the the points on the plane or the
points on the on the sphere and of
course you can think of of many many
other examples as well this is what we
call the domain
we write it as omega it's typically it's
a set first of all and it may have some
additional structure so in the case of
uh of the sphere it has some interesting
topology
uh and typically we also want to think
about the geometry want to think about
distances and angles
so it's a set with some kind of
structure
and in addition it has some symmetries
meaning there are some transformations
we can do to this uh set that will
preserve the structure that we think is
important so if we think distances are
important uh on uh let's say the sphere
when the kinds of symmetries we we end
up with are rotations three-dimensional
rotations of the sphere and perhaps also
reflections in the case of a graph the
symmetries would be permutations of the
of the nodes and uh also
you know a corresponding permutation of
the of the edges
uh so you just change the order of the
nodes if node one and two were connected
and you apply permutation and move those
to node three and four then now three
and four has to be connected so that's
it that's a symmetry of our space oh we
got
now the data uh this is a very important
point the data are typically not points
in this space so when we're classifying
images well our space is the plane but
the data are not points in the plane
they're not the two-dimensional vectors
the data is really a signal uh on the
plane a two-dimensional image which so
you can think of that as a function from
for each point in the plane we have a
pixel value
um
so in more general cases it might be
something called a field so you might
say have wind direction on uh on earth
uh that's a signa there's a vector field
on the sphere now the symmetries that we
talked about they act on this space
you could show how they automatically
also act on the space of signals so
those are the key ingredients to define
what a feature space is you have your
your space omega it's a set of nodes
sphere whatever
then you have a group of symmetries of
that space and then you have the space
of signals or feature maps uh on this
space and you have the group acting on
your signal so you can rotate a vector
field or you can
shift a planar image or etc
so those are the key ingredients to
define a
feature space and then we can talk about
layers and so the layers or maps of the
network
they have to respect this structure so
if we have a signal on uh on the sphere
uh and we believe that rotating it
doesn't let's change it in any essential
way or we permute the nodes in the graph
but it's still the same graph
then we want the layers of the network
to respect that and to respect this
structure means to be active variant to
the symmetries
so if we apply our transformation to our
signal
and then we apply our network layer
it should be the same uh as applying the
network layer to the original input and
then applying a transformation in the
output space
now how the transformation acts in the
output space could be different from the
input space so for example
uh you could have a vector field as
input
uh and the scalar field is output they
transform differently so that's why for
each layer network you're going to have
a different feature space with a
different action of the group
but it's the same group acting in each
feature space the maps they should be
equivariant
and these maps they include both the
linear maps which are typically the the
learnable layers
uh and the non-linearities
now for linear maps you can study all
sorts of interesting questions you can
ask what is the most general kind of
equivariant linear map
and it turns out that for a large class
of group actions
or linear group actions
the
most general kind of equigent linear
maps are
generalized forms of convolutions so
that's really an explanation for why
convolutions are so ubiquitous
uh the final ingredient uh that i think
is key to the success of many
architectures is some kind of pooling or
coarsening operation
so the structures we've talked about so
far are you know this global space and
the symmetries on it etc but typically
there's also a notion of distance or
locality
in our space
and if we
just enforce
that our layers have to respect the
symmetries well that would force us to
use a convolution in many cases and i
just mentioned
uh but not uh forces to use local
filters and we all know that using sort
of global filters is not going to be
very effective use of parameters
um so uh locality is is the other key
thing locality of the filters uh and
also locality is exploited via some kind
of pooling of coursing operation
now going forward to say the year 2020
deep learning is all the craze right now
and so many different deep learning
architectures are being proposed
convolutional neural networks graph
neural networks lstms and so on when
these architectures are being proposed
different terminologies are used because
people tend to come from different areas
when they're proposing them and also
they are usually followed by kinds of
bombastic statements such as everything
can be seen as a special case of a
convolutional neural network
transformers use self-attention and
attention is all you need graph neural
networks work on graphs and everything
can be represented as a graph and
lstms are turing complete so why would
you ever need anything else so i hope
that this illustrates how the field of
deep learning in the year of 2020 is
really not all that different from the
state of geometry in the 1800s and if
history is teach us anything about how
we can unify these fields together now
is the right time for us to look back
study the geometric principles
underlying the architectures that we use
and as a result we might just derive a
blueprint that will allow us to reason
about all the architectures we have in
the past but also any architectures that
we might come up with in the future and
in my opinion that is the key selling
point of our recently released proto
book and i hope that it is helpful in
guiding deep learning research going
forward i should highlight that i was
also extremely
extremely honored to deliver the first
version of the talk presenting our proto
book at frederick alexander university
of erlang in
exactly the same place where the
erlangen program was originally brought
up
albeit because of the existing coveted
restrictions i had to do so in a virtual
manner
so i think a lot of people understand
convolutions in the way of a traditional
planar cnn and the mathematical notion
of a convolution which is very closely
related to you know a fourier transform
for example but um graph convolutional
networks they seem to abstract the
notion of a convolution into some kind
of concept of the neighborhood and local
connectivity and some of your work as
well with um
you know equivariant convolutional
neural networks i think do the same
thing so when we talk about convolution
are we talking about a very abstract
notion of it uh yeah that's a great
question uh i i think that uh there are
so many different ways to get at
convolution
uh you can uh
you can think of it in sort of you
trying to think of it in terms of
sliding a filter over some space right
so you put it in a canonical position
and then you slide it around
uh that is an idea that you can
generalize to not just sliding over a
plane but say applying some
transformation from a group to your
filter so let's say you're you have a
filter on the sphere
uh then you can you have
you know the sphere has a symmetry group
mainly three-dimensional rotations group
so3 you can apply an element of s of
three a three-dimensional rotation to
your filter even sort of slide it over
uh over the over the sphere that leads
to something called group convolution
so that's one way to to think about it
um there is indeed as you mentioned the
spectral way of looking at it so you
could think
there's the the famous fourier
convolution theorem uh which says that
to that in the spectrum uh a convolution
is just a pointwise product
uh so one way to implement a convolution
would be to take a fourier transform of
your signal your feature map and a
fourier transform of your filter
multiply them point wise
and then inverse fourier transform to
get the the result uh and this
perspective also generalizes so it
generalizes to graphs
where the fourier transform
or something analogous to it
um can be obtained via graph laplacians
uh as well as some some other ideas
that is actually historically how some
of the first graph neural nets were
implemented and motivated
uh there's also a spectral theory for
for group convolutions so
indeed um the
the fourier transform can be generalized
uh for uh or the standard fourier
transform that we all know is actually
the fourier transform for the plane the
plane being a particular group uh the
translation group in two dimensions so
there is a whole of a very beautiful
theory uh of uh uh of let's say four
eight generalized fourier transforms
four groups
uh where now the spectrum uh
is uh
is indexed
not not by the just by the integers as
it is the case for the uh uh for the
for the line or the plane
uh but by something called irreducible
representations in case of the plane
those are indeed indexed by integers
and the um
uh the spectrum is not just scalar
valued or complex scalar value but it
can be matrix valued uh if you're
interested in this sort of stuff you can
uh you want sort of a very high level
description you can check out our paper
on spherical cnns where we actually
implement convolution on a sphere uh
using this kind of generalized fourier
transform
um so that's a fourier perspective on
convolutions
and there's a final uh perspective which
i think is quite uh
uh
intuitive
which is that
the convolution is the most general kind
of equivariant linear map uh between
certain
group between certain linear group
actions
so specifically
the these group actions are
the way that groups tend to act on the
space of signals on uh your space so we
might have space of scalar signals on
the sphere
and your feature map you might want to
have another scalar signal on the sphere
or a vector field on the sphere or
something then you can ask what is it
most general kind of equivalent linear
map and the answer is it's a convolution
and that is also true in a very general
uh setting so that that to me is the
most intuitive way of understanding
convolutions as the most general kind of
maps that are linear maps that are
equivalent to to certain kinds of group
actions
professor bruner welcome to mlst is an
absolute honor to have you on um
introduce yourself
yeah um hi tim i'm joanne bruna i'm an
associate professor at the quran
institute and center for data science at
new york university and i'm very happy
to be here chatting with you at the mlst
juwan you just released this geometric
deep learning proto book you know what
does it mean to you what was your kind
of intellectual journey that led to this
yeah so this journey in fact uh started
many years ago so um
i would say even like during my postdoc
i was a postdoc
i was doing my postdoc here at nyu with
uh young lee kun
and that was the time 2013
where you know confidence were already
uh um showing a you know big promise uh
in image class and uh discussing with
jan
the the questions are okay how about uh
domains that are not like grades right
so and that was the
beginning of a journey that also
included my former collaborator artus
lamp was like another researcher in the
lab that had a similar background as me
like coming from applied math but
looking into into into more and more
deep learning so i would say that the
genesis was
our first attempt at extending the
success of convolutional neural networks
to these um reliable domains and we
published the paper at the clear 2014
and after that i think things started
like quite naturally because other
researchers that
i would say
came from the same background like you
know maybe from geometric background
also started to realize that there was
something there maybe bigger than these
particular papers in particular michael
bronstein uh
it's kind of reached out to us
just afterwards saying oh and we are
also looking at similar ideas i think we
should just team together and start to
to think about this more globally and so
uh
you know things that developed from
there and we wrote this uh every a
journal paper like a read paper in 2017
with uh arthur jan michael pierre van
der geis who is another very well known
figure in this area and so from there i
think that yeah things like started to
slightly take off we had tutorials and
nerves that we had a very um successful
workshop at ipam
after this i think that the
the thing we're clear that okay maybe at
some point in the future we should try
to stamp all these things into a book
that tries to reflect something a bit
more
let's say mature and you know what is
our
if we wanted to have like some kind of
legacy for future generations on how to
implement and and communicate these
methods how would that be so i guess
that was the genesis of the book and so
um
uh very soon we said with michael that
we also would like to have some
you know fresh minds and fresh energy on
board so naturally the the names of taco
and better uh came very naturally to us
as people who were have been doing
excellent work in the domain that would
very nicely complement uh our skills so
the team was created
and uh and that's what that project and
so um
yeah i mean i think it's been very
interesting so far
of course i guess that as you know this
is just a uh in uh ongoing project right
so it's still not not been finalized
but hopefully we're getting uh interest
from the community and this this gives
us some kind of uh i would say positive
vibes to finish it on time as you know
writing books is always like this never
ending process so i think that uh yeah
that's it
it's been an interesting uh endeavor so
far for sure
i asked professor bronstein what his
most passionately held belief is about
machine learning i think machine
learning is such a field where holding
strong beliefs is often
counterproductive
it happened to me multiple times that
something that i thought or said
was very quickly overturned and what i
mean is that
milestones or progress was achieved much
faster than i could even imagine in a
wild dream
so making predictions about machine
learning is to some extent an ungrateful
job
i do however believe that in order to
make progress to the next level and make
machine learning achieve its potential
to become the transformative technology
we trust and use ubiquitously it must be
built on solid mathematical foundations
and i also think that machine learning
will drive future scientific
breakthroughs and probably a good litmus
test would be a nobel prize awarded for
a discovery made by
or with the help of an ml system
it might already happen in the next
decade
i wanted to go into a few questions
actually uh about the book so um uh
first of all joanne in your 2017 paper
the mathematics of deep learning you
cited the universal function
approximation theorem which is to say
the ability of a shallow neural network
to approximate arbitrary functions but
the performance of wide and shallow
neural networks can be significantly
beaten by deep networks and you said
that one of the possible explanations is
that deep architectures are able to
better capture invariant properties of
the data compared to their shallow
counterparts um could you just briefly
introduce the universal function
approximation theorem and do you think
it's still relevant for today's neural
networks
yeah i mean that's a that's a very
deep and an important question yeah so
universal approximation theorem it
refers to this very
general principle that once you define a
parametric class let's say you're uh you
are learn functions using null nets it
just describes this your ability that as
you put more and more parameters into
your class you're gonna be able to uh to
approximate essentially anything that
data nature throws at you and so uh
this might seem like a very powerful
property but in fact
um
in fact it's it's it's something that it
you have probably already encountered
many times during your undergrad i mean
if you have any let's say
background in uh you know sigma
processing electrical engineering
there's many ways in which
students have learned how to represent
data like signals for example using
fourier transform so fourier transforms
are an instance of a class that has
universal approximation so in that sense
it's a
i think going back to the second part of
your question how relevant it is to in
the context of neural networks and um
how far does this thing push us towards
understanding why deep learning works
so i would say there's a there's two
sides of the answer on one hand
i think that universal approximation
is is a tool that
when you combine it with other
elements it becomes something that
provides
good guiding principles for instance
universal approximation of a generic
function we know that yeah we can as i
said we can obtain it with you know
very very naive architectures for
example just a shallow neural network
without any kind of physical structure
special structure already has this
property
does it actually help us to to learn
very efficiently no right and i'm gonna
go at this afterwards but when you
combine it for example with uh you know
let's say that now your data
lives on a graph or your data
i don't know has a certain uh like come
from a physical lab that has certain
properties let's say that it's
rotationally invariant
like the first thing that that the
designer like a domain scientist would
like to know if you come there and you
design your neural network look i have a
neural net that i trick sticks detects
your data and has very good performance
the first thing that you will ask is
okay
how general is your architecture right
can it explain anything that they could
throw with you it seems like it's a in
that sense i would i would present it
more
as a sufficient condition like a check
mark that your your you know your
architecture needs to fall right if you
make more and more parameters can you
express more and more
elements functions from your class
but then as i said this is far from
being uh
sufficient right it's like it's a sorry
it's a it's a necessary condition but
it's far from being sufficient in the
sense that
um
universal approximation uh
has a flavor it's a result that does not
quantify how many parameters do i need
right like you know if i want to
approximate functions let's say i want
to classify between different dot braids
it doesn't tell me this theorem doesn't
tell me how many parameters how many
neurons do i need for that right it's
it's a statement that in that sense uh
it lets it leaves you a little bit with
your uh like say like uh you know like a
like it's a bittersweet result right it
doesn't it doesn't really tell you
anything actually so that's why
and that's why we enter this uh this uh
other question that is actually much
deeper and to some extent still written
by pretty much open
that is
how do you actually go from this this
statement to something that is
quantitative write something that tells
you okay
you know you need that many layers you
need that many parameters
and so this is where the role of depth
in neural networks is uh
you know becomes essentially the key
open question
and and yeah so in this in this quote
that you thought that you brought from
this paper
that kind of reflected our understanding
at the time of uh maybe
the true power of universal
approximation
is you know when as you combine it with
this other prior that is the asymmetries
of the data like the invariances so i
don't want to represent arbitrary
functions i only want to represent
functions that are invariant to certain
transformations of the input
so
in fact
our at least my particular
you know view of the problem analysis of
the problem has somehow evolved in the
last years right of course through a
research that i've done together with my
collaborators and now and and this is
actually the way we present it in the
book
we we
we kind of identify
two different flavors two different
sources of prior information that one
needs to bake into the problem right to
to really go beyond this like basic
approximation result of neural nets the
first one you need is invariance right
is a disability that you you need to
break the fact that you actually put
symmetries into the architecture is
certainly going to have a benefit in
terms of sample complexity right they i
mean you are going to learn more
efficiently if your model is aware of
the symmetries of the world
but in fact this this prior
in fact we know now
that it's not sufficient right if you
only like agnostically build your
learning system
just with these symmetries in mind
indeed you are going to become more
efficient than a system that is
completely agnostic to symmetries but it
might not be you might not be able to
formally establish what we call like a
like a learning guarantee that has good
sample complexity and i guess that i
don't want to go too much into the
jargon and the details of what this
means but the idea is that if i want to
you know learn this function with
certain precision
how many examples how many training
examples do i need to kind of give you a
certification like a guarantee that i'm
going to be able to do that so with
symmetries alone it's not something that
we know how to do in fact we are
we believe we have strong beliefs that
it's not possible right there's a
examples out there that i could i could
you know construct a
function that has the right symmetries
has the right priors if you want
but still needs a lot a lot of examples
to build to learn so what we need is to
add something else into the mix and this
is this something that we call in the in
the book this scale separation
and and and if you want i can try to
very briefly give you an intuitive idea
of what this means
so
if you think about the problem of
classifying an image like a dog or the
cat so what is given to you is like a
big bunch of pixels right every pixel
has a color value so somehow you need to
figure out
uh the thing that you're looking for is
lying in some kind of like it's really
through the interactions between pixels
that you get the answer right and the
question is
of course if i have a thousand pixels
how many possible interactions do i have
between thousand elements so this is
where this exponential of the cursive
dimensionality appears right i need to a
priori i should be looking at all
possible families of interactions
between pixels and these are maybe where
my signal would be live of course if i
need to look for all of these things
it's impossible right there's just too
many things
uh if i tell you that the you know these
interactions are such that there's this
translation symmetry well you might not
be you know
you you might not be needing to look at
all of them but in fact you don't need
you you do not throw enough so what what
is really something that is powerful is
that i tell you that maybe the
interactions that matter the most are
those between a pixel and its neighbors
right and if you understand very well if
you base your initial learning steps
into understanding well which local
interaction matters
maybe you can use them to bootstrap the
interactions that that will be to look
at this neighborhood to slightly bigger
neighborhoods right and so this idea
that you can break a very complicated
problem into a families of sub problems
that lives in different scales
this is at the i would say at the
intuitive level
something print like at the core at the
essence of why these architectures are
so efficient
this idea as you might
imagine is not new it's not specific to
deep learning the idea that you can take
a complicated system of interacting
particles and break it into different
scales
these are the at the basis of
essentially all of physics and chemistry
right there's many many you know like
when people study even like biology life
right
you have you have experts that are very
experts at the molecular level then you
have experts that you know might
understand like you know doctors that
understand things at the level of okay
functions and then there's maybe experts
at the level of the society right but
this you know it's pretty natural to
break the a very complicated thing into
different scales and so the neural
networks somehow are able to do that we
don't have the full mathematical picture
right of for example why this scale
separation is strictly necessary what we
know from empirical evidence like that
is now i would say indisputable is that
this is an efficient way to do that
right because when i was when i was
reading the proto book i noticed that
there was a separation between the the
symmetries and the scale separation
could you explain in simple terms why is
the scale separation not just a symmetry
as well because it seemed a little bit i
don't want to say kludgy but it seemed
like um you had this scale matter and
you dealt with it separately yeah that's
a good that's a good point so so maybe
that the way to to to separate these two
would be
if you think about uh like an
algorithmic instantiation if you want to
have a network that would just break the
problem into different skills it would
be like a neural network that
would operate the different patches and
for every page of the image i could be
learning independent set of parameters
right so that would be a model
that is only told that it should be
breaking the problem into different
regions but it's not necessarily told
that you know there's a weight sharing
right there's some kind of like
parameter sharing that somehow uh is you
are able that you know in a sentence is
helping you to learn with fewer number
of parameters so somehow these these two
these two conditions are
uh slightly complementary uh we as i
said there's still like a lot of
mathematical puzzles as to how these
things interact optimally um
and i think that the the the one of the
reasons why we chose to explain the
story into two different in these two
different priors is that they all
survive this quest fortunately in the
sense that these two principles
are
again something that you can think about
for grids for groups for graphs
you can also see these principles
appearing completely everywhere as you
study physical systems right like the
the scale and the symmetry is are really
at the core of uh of um
many physical theories and and i would
say that there's also
um
you know at the more maybe technical
level
these two priors
somehow have been instrumental
to
organize like to basically to have a
kind of a recipe to build architectures
right so so maybe now we don't even
think about it right but when you have a
new problem a new domain and you need to
build an efficient neural network
we automatically have this this idea
that okay we are going to start learning
by composition right so we are going to
extract the information one layer at a
time that's the first appearance of
scale and we know that the way we need
to organize these layers right how do
you parameterize a layer that
takes some input features and produces
maybe better features
this idea that we do that by
understanding this kind of equivariance
structure right we we we have this
notion of filters right in in in
convolutional networks we have this i
said we we organize everything in terms
of filters when we talk about message
graphical we have this kind of like a
diffusion filters right and and so
there's this object that we extract from
the domain that is helping us giving us
something very constructive very
you know very like very practical and so
this is really the this underlying group
of transformations that is acting on our
domain and so i would say that you know
from a practitioner's perspective
these are these these two principles
right that i'm gonna learn by composing
some some uh like fundamental layer that
i repeat all the time and the way this
layer is organized is structured uh
through this like group transformation
this has been i would say like like a
trademark of uh you know the success of
neural networks of course as also we
mentioned in the book
this is these are i would say
proto-like meta uh
you know meta parameterization right in
the sense that there's as you know many
many many uh variants that people have
come up with many many let's say yeah
like modifications on the basic
architecture that have really make
dramatic changes in performance right so
there's um
there there's of course as i say like
the devil sometimes it's in the details
right and so as as we are writing the
book we are realizing exactly you know
uh how some of the changes in the
architectures are actually fit into this
what we call this blueprint right this
symmetric deep learning blueprint
fascinating okay so i wanted to come
back to what you were saying a few
minutes ago about the um the sample
efficiency of these models now um
with graph neural networks for example
there are factorially many permutations
of adjacency matrices for a given graph
and um
i want to talk about a sorting algorithm
right so francois schwarle came on the
podcast and he said that in order to
learn a sorting algorithm that
generalizes you would need to learn
point by point you would need to see
factorially
many
examples of permutations of numbers
do you think that we could train a
neural network to learn a sorting i
guess what i'm asking in a roundabout
way is do you think there's a kind of
geometry to computation itself
good that's a very good question and in
fact uh we have some um some recent work
with uh some collaborators in my group
where we kind of take up this question
from and we try to formalize it
mathematically
and we give answers to this question and
so
um many of these like a computational
tasks that uh that you were mentioning
for example sorting or you know like um
like algorithm right like algorithmic
tasks they are if one wants to put them
into some mathematical context the first
thing that comes to mind is these are
functions that already enjoy some
symmetries for example like a sorting
algorithm right is invariant to
permutations right so the function that
you are trying to learn is a an
arbitrary function that has this
symmetric class
and so as such as i was saying in the
beginning you can
try to address this question uh saying
okay now you give me an arbitrary so so
the question would be
relative to an arbitrary learning
learner that is agnostic to symmetry how
much does a symmetric learner gain right
so you can basically like try to
understand quantify the gains of sample
complexity of learning without symmetry
versus learning with symmetry
and so uh the the the punch line of this
work that recent work that we that we
completed is that one can actually
quantify the sample complexity gains and
these are of the order of the size of
the group
and so
here in the case of like permutations
what it means is that if a learner is
aware of this symmetry
like one training example of the
symmetric learner is roughly equivalent
to
n factorial samples of the agnostic
learner right which is a something that
you would expect like if you think in
terms of data mentation right like
if i if i if i tell you in advance that
your function is symmetric is invariant
to permutations it's you know like a
brute force approach would say okay you
give me an instant training an input
right and instead of giving you this
input i'm just gonna you know
like permute like have any possible
permutation of the input and you already
know the output right so you can as well
fit it to the learner
so this is like heuristic and this
addition turns out to be mathematically
correct precise at least you know under
some conditions right but but the i
guess that the whole point is that
these gains might look amazing like
might look like a you know
like a big boost in in supple complexity
as i said before
there's a grain of salt here is that the
in these conditions in these general
conditions you are already fighting
essentially an impossible problem in the
sense that the rate like the sample
complexity is dominated by a rate of
basically the the the rate in which you
learn is what we call curves by
dimension in this what it means is that
if i want to you know
i have a certain performance uh
generalization error
and let's say that now i want to ask you
the question if i want to divide this
generalization error by two
how many more samples do i need to give
you right like well so if i want to
double you know like a double like
reduce the my error by half
by how much do i need to give you more
samples so this dependency in fact is
exponential in dimension right so
basically the
the
the sample complexity gains by
invariance they are exponential in
dimension
but they are fighting an impossible
problem that is already caused by
dimensions so what it means is that at
the end of the day
uh
this is what what you know um what was
in the in the like in the heart of what
i saying before is that invariance alone
might not be efficient might not be
sufficient right because you are okay
you are taking a very hard problem you
are removing an exponential factor but
you still have many x you know you have
still have something in the exponent
that is exponential right so so so what
it means is that uh um that i mean that
that's what really uh underpins why we
think in this terms of x combining
symmetry prior with this scale
separation prior but uh certainly the
algorithmic tasks are a very interesting
playground because um i i think that for
the case of sorting um
i mean as you know uh skill separation
is also an issue it's also a very
important thing right i mean it this is
what basically is at the heart of the
dynamic programming approaches right
like these efficient algorithms that are
not only efficiently statistically but
also efficiently computational right
this idea that you can divide and
conquer so so so so algorithmic tasks
also are kind of exposed to this dual
physical right of a scale and in
variance on the cursive dimensionality
there's this issue where you have a data
point and you want to surround it by
other data points in two dimensions to
create a convex hull
and
as you increase the number of dimensions
the number of data points you need to
create this covering um to create a kind
of interpolative space increases
exponentially and when you get past a
certain number of dimensions let's say
16 or not not very many you would need
essentially more data points than there
are atoms in the universe
so this leads to a very interesting
realization
i think some people refer to it as the
manifold hypothesis which is that most
natural data is only really spatially
novel on very few dimensions and a lot
of data falls on very smooth low
dimensional manifolds but what are the
implications of this
essentially all machine learning
problems that we need to deal nowadays
are extremely high dimensional so even
if we take very modestly sized
images
they live in thousands or even in
millions of dimensions and
if you think of machine learning or at
least the simplest settings
of machine learning as a kind of
glorified function interpolation the the
standard approach is to function
interpolation is just
use the data points to
to predict the values of your function
will simply not work because of the
phenomena of course of the recursive
dimensionality that increasing the
number of dimensions the number of such
points blows up exponentially so what
you really need to take into account and
probably this is really what makes
machine learning work in practice is the
assumption that there is some intrinsic
structure to the data and it can be
captured in different ways so it's
either the manifold assumption where you
can assume that the data even though it
lives in a very high dimensional space
intrinsically it is low dimensional this
can be captured also in the form of
symmetry for example uh image is not
just a high dimensional vector it has
underlying grid structure and grid
structure has symmetry this is what
captured in convolutional networks in
the form of shared weights that
translates into the convolution
operation i think the symmetries are
part of the magic here because it's not
just the interesting observation that
natural data
is only spatially novel in so few
dimensions there's something magic about
symmetries and when we spoke to francois
charles recently he invoked the
kaleidoscope effect which is this notion
that almost all information in reality
is a copy of some other information
probably here it will be a little bit
stretching but i would say that because
data comes from nature from physical
processes that produce it
physics and nature itself is in a sense
low dimensional so it's
application of simple rules at multiple
scales you can create very complex
systems with very simple rules and this
is probably how our data that we are
mostly interested in machine learning is
structured so you have this
manifestation of symmetry and
self-similarity through different scales
the principles of symmetry and certain
environments or equivalence and of scale
separation where you can separate your
problem to multiple scales and
deal with it at different levels of
resolution and this is captured for
example in pooling operations in
convolutional neural networks and in
other deep learning architectures this
is what uh makes deep learning systems
work fascinating it's so good that you
raised the cursive dimensionality
because i was going to ask you about
that could you explain in really simple
terms so not invoking lip ships
i can't even say it properly enough but
you know not invoking a mathematical
jargon and why exactly in your um
articulation does geometric deep
learning
reduce the impact of the curse of
dimensionality
yeah so the curse of dimensionality it
it refers generally
to them
to the inability
of algorithms
to keep certifying certain performance
as the data becomes more complex and
data becoming more complex here means
that you have more and more
dimensions right more and more pixels
and so this inability
of you know like scaling basically it's
like it really says that if i scale up
the input
my algorithm is going to have more and
more trouble to keep the base and so
this this curse
can take different flavors right so this
curse might might might have like a
statistical reason in the sense that as
i make my input space bigger
there would be many many many much
exponentially more uh functions real
functions out there that would explain
the training set that would basically
pass through the tingling points
and so the more dimensions i add the
more uncertainty i have about the the
true function right so i would need more
and more training samples to keep the
base
these the curves can also be from the
approximation side right so in the sense
that my the number of neurons that i
mean that i'm considering to approximate
my target function i need to keep adding
more and more neurons at the rate that
is exponential in dimension
under and the curves can also be from
the computational side right the the
sense that the if i keep adding
parameters and parameters
to my training model i might have to
optimize the you know to to to solve an
optimization problem that becomes
exponentially harder
and so you can see that you are
basically bombarded by three different
by all angles and so uh an algorithm
like you know here in the context of
statistical learning or learning theory
if you want having a kind of a
theorem that would say yes i can promise
you that you can learn you need to
actually solve these three problems at
once right you need to be able to say
that that in their conditions that
you're studying you have an algorithm
that it does not suffer from
approximation nor statistical nor
computational courses
so as you can imagine it's it's very
hard right because then you need to to
master many things at the same time so
why do we think that geometry deep
learning is at least an important piece
to overcome this curse as i said
before so uh geometric deep learning is
really
a device to put more structure into the
target function right so basically to
make the learning problem easier because
we are we you know we are we are
promising the learner more properties
about the target function right we are
basically making the hypothesis class if
you want smaller
uh
that said as i said there's there's
still some path to go right as we were
describing just a bunch of principles
that make this hypothesis spaces smaller
and more adapted to the real world
but one thing that we are still lacking
for example is the guarantee in terms of
optimization right i mean i described
that the depth of these architectures is
somehow something that is akin
associated with the scale right the fact
that you need to understand things at
different scales
so
as you know in the from the optimization
side there's still some open questions
and open mysteries as to why the
gradient descent for example is able to
find good solutions right so these are
things that uh you know we believe
that these architectures can be
optimized officially just because we
have this experimental evidence that is
piling up
but we are for example we are still
lacking
theoretical guarantees
for the approximation we it's a bit of
the same story right so we understand
very well approximation properties of
shallow networks
starting from universal approximation
but of course many many recent
interesting work but we are also still
lagging a little bit behind
in approximation properties for deeper
networks so as you see it's like
you can you can see from from this
discussion that
yes we have some you know
good reasons to believe that these are
fundamental principles of learning but
there's also a bunch of mathematical
questions that are still open and and
and this is
also one of the things that i like about
writing a book on this topic because
it's a very live domain right it's not
you know
as you can see the field is still
evolving and and it's a i think it's a
good time to
yeah it's a good time i mean if
researchers out there are listening to
us it's a good time to to
think and to work and to join this
program
amazing will we ever understand the
approximation properties of deep
networks because with the um the shallow
you know function approximation
algorithm it's you can almost think of a
neural network as being kind of like
sparse coding and you know the more
neurons you have you're just kind of
discreetly fitting this arbitrary
function but you don't have that visual
intuition quite so much with the deep
networks
yeah i mean it's um it's an important
and it's a deep question so so in the
shallow neural networks i really really
correspond to this idea that you learn a
function by stacking a linear
combination of basis elements right and
and this is really at the roots of
essentially
all of harmonic analysis so
functionalized right you typically think
about the basis and you ask questions
about the linear approximation or
approximation et cetera
deeply deep neural networks they
introduce a fundamentally different way
to approximate functions that is by
composing right by composition and so
you're right uh our knowledge about this
question uh right now
is mostly concentrated in what we call
separation results like a depth
separation which
consists in trying to find construct
mathematical examples of functions that
cannot be approximated with shallower
networks with certain number of neurons
but indeed they can be much better
approximated with different networks
right so this is really understanding
which kind of functions benefit
fundamentally from composition rather
than from addition
and so there's a certain mathematical
you know
vision of mathematical intuition that is
building up but of course it's still
very far from from under explaining that
the true power of the depth and just to
give you like a final pointer here
there's there's a very related
question that replaces neural networks
as we understand them with what we call
boolean functions right like these are
just the circuits arithmetic circuits
that take as input some bit string and
they can manipulate the bits by you know
add
or operations and operations and they
can keep adding gates and so this
question about what is the ability of a
certain circuit architecture to
approximate certain boolean functions is
actually a notoriously hard and and
basically has been studied in the in the
theoretical computer science community
since the 50s and the 60s right and
there's a actually very very very deep
results and very challenging actually
open questions concerning these things
so so this is really we are really
touching here questions that are
pretty serious at the at like the deep
mathematical and theoretical level and
so
yes uh you should not expect that in the
year in the next year two we have a
complete understanding of you know
approximation powers of any architecture
with any depth
but i think you should expect
that the
theory like this will
continue to try to catch up with the
with the with uh with the experiments
and so we are i think we yeah i think we
we are hoping to to to get like a more
precise mathematical understanding of
the role of depth and uh and as i said
before um there's all one thing that is
fascinating about this this domain that
is maybe very unique to deep learning is
this very strong interaction between
optimization
uh statistics and approximation right
maybe it turns out that you know the
like the huge step that we have in this
residual neural networks might not be
necessary from the approximation side
but in fact it's so useful for the
optimization that every that overall is
a big a big winner right so there's all
these always these like twists about
this question that that that are
fundamentally mixing these three sources
of error i'm sorry for asking you this
question but can neural networks
extrapolate outside of the training data
um
that's a good that's a yeah that's a
it's a
it's a good question uh i i would say
that the answer
i guess depends on on your
specifications right so i guess that
the
the conservative answer uh of us you
know a statistical learning person would
be
no because we don't have good theorems
right now that tell us that this is the
case
uh there's
very like you know like a strong
effort both from the practical and the
theoretical community to really
understand
this question like by trying to
formalize it a bit more i mean what do
we mean by distribution shift you know
what kind of a training procedures you
can come up with that would give you
precisely this kind of robustness
there's of course what we call these
biases right i mean uh
i can always take it like a training
distribution i make a choice of a
certain architecture i'm going to learn
a function and obviously there are some
directions if you want in the space of
distributions for which my hypothesis
will turn out to be have good
generalization there might be other
direction in which the the country is
true so there's actually very nice work
for from stephanie alcaz group at mit
where they for example they studied this
question in the context of value
networks also including graphs where
they for example they discover or they
identify this strong preference for
radio networks to generalize along
linear directions right in the sense
that if i just decide to now you know
shift my data in linear directions then
my function has no trouble generalizing
maybe there's other directions right in
which this thing is actually
catastrophic so i think that yeah the
question i think it's it's very
important
from um
let's say
it's it's it's very important from a
kind of a practitioner perspective right
that's typical that's clearly something
that a user would like to know but i
think that from a more mathematical a
theoretical level i think we are still
at the stage of trying to formalize like
okay what do we exactly mean by
extrapolation and what are the kind of
the the conditions for with architecture
can do it and i think that yeah this is
a yeah it's an important question but uh
yeah i think we are still pretty far
from having a full answer
amazing and and final question uh what
areas of mathematics do people need to
study before reading the proto book
uh good question so i think that uh our
um our objective and our really like the
the yeah like our idea is really to to
have something that is quite
self-contained in the sense that we are
gonna provide uh appendices
that uh expand on the areas that is
maybe they are not typically
kind of the bread and butter of machine
learning people for example we are going
to have an appendix on group theory uh
different differential geometry uh
harmonic analysis so these are areas
that i think are going to be there for
you to delve into into to get like the
most of the paper the most of the book
but i think that other than that
any basic you know any basic knowledge
of linear algebra statistics and
analysis will will do so like if you
have taken a graduate level class on
machine learning you should be ready to
go
rather than just being applied in a lot
of really important branches of research
problems
people outside of pure research have
recognized that a lot of the data that
comes to us from nature is most
naturally represented in a graph
structured form very rarely will nature
give us something that can be
representable as an image or a sequence
that's super rare so very often the
structure is more irregular more
graph-like and therefore graph neural
networks have already seen a lot of
applications
in domains where the data is
supernaturally represented as a graph in
the domain of computational chemistry
where you can represent molecules as
graphs of atoms and bonds between them
the graph neural networks have already
proven impactful in detecting
novel potent antibiotics that previously
were completely overlooked because of
their unusual structure
in the area of chip design graph neural
networks are powering systems that are
developing the latest generation of
google's machine learning chips the tpu
furthermore graph structured data is
super ubiquitous
in social networks and the kinds of
networks maintained by
many
big industry players and accordingly
graphene networks are already used to
serve various kinds of content in
production to billions of users
on a daily basis in fact the
recommendation system at pinterest the
product recommendation system at amazon
as well as the food recommendation
system for ubereats all of them are
powered using a graph neural network
that helps serve the most relevant
content to users on a daily basis
and on a slightly personal note
graph neural networks have also been
used to significantly improve travel
time predictions in google maps which
is used also by billions of people every
day so whenever you type a query how do
i get from point a to point b in the
most efficient way
the travel time prediction that you get
is powered by a graph neural network
that we have developed at deepmind in
collaboration with the google maps team
and this is of high importance not only
to users that use the app on a daily
basis to find the most efficient way to
travel it's also used by the various
companies that leverage the maps api so
they can tell their customers what's the
time it will take for a certain vehicle
to arrive to them so companies such as
food delivery companies and ride sharing
companies have also extensively profited
from the system which
in cities such as sydney has reduced the
relative amount of negative user
outcomes in terms of badly predicted
travel times by over 40 percent making
it one way in which uh graph
representation learning techniques that
i have co-developed are actively
impacting billions of people on a daily
basis
when i was an undergraduate student i
was interested in image processing and
was excited about variational methods
i think it's a very elegant idea that
you can define a functional
that serves as a model for your ideal
image and then use the optimality
conditions to derive a differential
equation that flows towards the optimum
and a particularly cool approach was
proposed by ron kimmel
where you could think of an image as a
manifold or a high-dimensional surface
and use an energy that originated in
string theory and particle physics
to derive a non-euclidean diffusion pde
called beltramiflow
that acts as a nonlinear image filter
and this is what made me fall in love
with differential geometry and
i did a phd with ron on this topic
and i think these were really beautiful
and deep ideas that unfortunately now
are almost forgotten in the era of deep
running and it's a pity that the machine
learning research community has such a
short memory because many modern
concepts have really ancient roots
ironically we've recently used
non-euclidean diffusion equations as a
way to reinterpret craft neural networks
as neural pdes and i think it really
helps sometimes to have a longer time
window now equivalent networks tend to
generalize much better and require much
less data
if the data indeed has the symmetry that
you assumed in your model
but people often ask you know why do we
even care about data efficiency when we
can just collect more data we live in
the era of big data right
and i think the answer why you might
still be interested in data efficiency
first of all there are applications like
say medical imaging where acquiring
labeled data simply is very cost you
have to get patients uh you're dealing
with privacy restrictions you're dealing
with costly highly trained doctors who
have to annotate the data come together
in a committee to decide on questionable
cases and so forth so this is very
expensive and if you can you can improve
the data efficiency by a factor of 2 or
10 or whatever it may be you might just
take a problem that was in the realm of
economically infeasible and take it into
the realm of the economically feasible
which is a very useful thing
there are other cases like
graphical nets where the group of
symmetries is so large in this case n
factorial number of permutations that no
amount of data or data augmentation in
practice is going to allow you to learn
the symmetry or to learn the invariants
or equivalents in your your knuckle so
indeed you see that in this space of
graph neural nets everybody uses
equivariate permutation equivalent
network architectures and finally you
could think about the grand problems of
agi artificial general intelligence and
so forth
and here i think that we will most
certainly need large data sets
large networks a lot of compute power
and so forth and the current
architectures we have clearly are
performing far fewer computations than
the human brain so there's a ways to go
there but i also think that one
essential characteristic of intelligence
is the ability to learn quickly in new
situations situations that are not
similar to
the the ones you've seen in your
training data
and so
data efficiency to me is an essential
characteristic of intelligence it's
almost like an action that you want your
method to be data efficient and so i
think one of the big challenges for the
field right now is to try to think of
very generic priors priors that apply in
a wide range of uh of situations and
they give you even though they're you
know generic and abstract they give you
a lot of bang for the buck in terms of
uh improved generalization and data
efficiency i think that the beauty of
science and research is in connecting
the dots
and i find it fascinating that for
example craft neural networks are
connected to the work of vice versa and
lemon from the 60s on isomorphism
testing which in turn was inspired by
problems in chemistry
and chemistry was also the field that
drove the research into modern
formulation of diffusion equations that
were adopted in image processing
community in the 90s and came back
recently as a way to reinterpret craft
neural networks and i think such
connections give really a new and deep
perspective and probably the deeper you
dive the broader they become but it's
really a never-ending story
today is an incredibly special episode
and we're filming at nine o'clock
in the morning
uh it's really rare for us to film this
early when i'm still caffeinated many of
our guests are over in the states it's
an absolute honor to have you both on
mlst and uh professor bronstein could
you start by briefly telling us how the
young mathematician eninoffer used
symmetries to discover the conservation
laws in physics
maybe i should take a step back and
describe the situation that that
happened
in the field of geometry towards the end
of the 19th century and
it was an incredibly fruitful
period of time for for mathematicians
working in this field with the discovery
and
development of different kinds of
geometries
so
a young mathematician based in germany
called felix klein proposed this quite
remarkable and groundbreaking idea that
you can define geometry by studying the
groups of symmetries basically the kinds
of transformations to which you can
subject geometric forms
and
seeing how different properties are
preserved or not under these
transformations so these ideas appear to
be very powerful and what amy neuter
showed in her work and she actually
worked in the same institution
where klein ended up in guttengen in
germany
and she showed that you can take a
physical system that is described as
functional as a variational system and
associate different conservation laws
with different uh symmetries of this
system
and it was a pretty remarkable result
because before that conservation laws
were purely empirical you would make an
experiment many times and measure for
example the energy before or after some
physical process or chemical reaction
and you would come to the conclusion
that the energy is preserved so this is
how for example i think lavoisier has
discovered the conservation of energy so
it was probably for the first time
that you could derive
these laws from first principles so you
would need to assume in case of
conservation of energy the symmetry of
time
we decided to take a tool into the world
of algorithmic reasoning
you said in your introduction that
algorithmic reasoning seeks to find
neural networks that are good at
imitating the classical algorithms that
initially brought you to computer
science so you recently released a paper
on this called neural algorithmic
reasoning and it's often claimed that
neural networks are turing complete and
you know we're told that we can think of
training neural networks as being a kind
of programmed search but you argued in
your paper that algorithms possess
fundamentally different qualities to
deep learning methods francois chalet
actually often points out that deep
learning algorithms would struggle to
represent a sorting algorithm without
learning point by point
you know which is to say without any
generalization power whatsoever but you
seem to be making the argument that the
interpretative function space of neural
networks can model algorithms more
closely to real-world problems
potentially finding more efficient and
pragmatic solutions than those
classically proposed by computer
scientists so what's your take yeah
thanks for asking that tim i think the
the concept of classical algorithms as
opposed to uh deep neural networks at
least the way we're currently applying
them makes all these points about turing
completeness a little bit moot because
there's quite a few proofs out there
saying that you can use neural networks
or
more recently graph neural networks in
particular to simulate a particular
algorithm perfectly but all of these
proofs are sort of a best case scenario
they're basically saying i can set the
weights of my neural network to these
particular values and voila i'm
imitating the algorithm perfectly right
so all these best case scenarios are
wonderful but in practice we don't use
this kind of best case optimization we
use stochastic gradient descent and
we're stuck with whatever stohasti
gradient descent gives us so in practice
the fact that a neural network is
capable for a particular setting of
weights to do something
doesn't mean that it will actually do
that when trained from data
so essentially
this is the kind of the big divide that
separates deep learning from traditional
algorithms
and it has a number of other issues as
well not just the fact that we cannot
find the best case solution
also the fact that
we are working in this high dimensional
space which is not necessarily easily
interpretable or composable because you
have no easy way of saying for example
in in theoretical computer science if
you want to compose two algorithms
you're working with them in a very
abstract space which means that you know
you can easily reason about stitching
the output of one to the input of
another whereas you cannot make that
easy of a claim about latent spaces of
two neural networks right so all these
kinds of properties interpretability
compositionality
and obviously also out of distribution
generalization are plagued not by the
fact that neural networks don't have the
capacity to do this but
the routines we use to optimize them are
not good enough to
to across that divide so in your
algorithmic reasoning all that we're
really trying to do is to bring these
two sides closer together by making
changes either in the structure of the
neural network or the training regime of
the neural network or the kinds of data
that we let the neural network see so
that hopefully it's going to
generalize better and extrapolate better
and
especially on the kinds of you know
classical algorithmic problems that we
might see in a computer science textbook
and lastly i think i'd just like to
address the point about
sorting
we have a
paper on algorithmic reasoning
benchmarks that we are about to submit
that in europe's dataset track i think
it should be public even now on github
because that's the requirement for the
conference
where we have quite a few algorithmic
tasks and we're trying to force gnns to
learn them and
we do have several sorting tasks in
there
and at least in distribution these
graphical networks are capable of
imitating the steps of say insertion
sort so
i will say not all is lost if you're
very careful about how you tune them but
obviously there is a lot of caveats and
i hope that later during this chat we'll
also get a chance to talk a little bit
about how even though we cannot
perfectly mimic algorithms we can still
use this concept of algorithmic
execution today now
to help expand the space of
applicability of albert
yeah this is absolutely fascinating
because this gets to the core of what i
think some people point out as being the
limitations of deep learning right and
charles spoke about this but um i don't
think that
geometric deep learning would help a
neural network learn a sorting function
because
discrete problems in general don't seem
amenable to vector spaces either because
the representation would be glitchy or
the problem is not interpretive in
nature or not learnable with stochastic
gradient descent so it would be
fascinating if we could overcome these
problems using continuous neural
networks as an algorithmic substrate do
you think we could
um i think that it is possible but it
will require us potentially to broaden
our lens on what we mean by geometric
deep learning and this is something
we're already very actively thinking
about i think one of our co-authors taco
cohen actually thought much more deeply
about this
in recent times but basically the idea
is we looked at geometric deep learning
from a group symmetry point of view
which is a very nice way to describe
spatial regularities and spatial
symmetries but
it's not necessarily the best way to
talk about say invariants of generic
computation which you would find in
algorithms right it's like i have input
that satisfies certain preconditions i
want to say something about once i push
it through this function it should
satisfy certain post conditions this is
not the kind of thing we can very easily
express
using the language of group theory
however it is something that perhaps we
could express more nicely using the
language of category theory which is an
area of math that i still don't know
enough about i'm currently actively
learning it but basically in the
language of category theory groups are
super simple categories that have just
one node right you can do a lot more
complicated things if you use this more
broader abstract language and you know
you talk about basically anything of
interest there in terms of these
commutative diagrams and taco actually
recently had a really interesting paper
called natural graph networks where they
basically generalized the notion of
permutation equivariance that you might
find in graph nets to
this more general concept of natural
transformations so now suddenly you
don't have to have a network that does
exactly the same transformation in every
single part of the graph
what you actually need is something a
bit more fine-grained
you just need for all like locally
isomorphic parts of the graph you need
to behave the same but in principle it
gives you a bit more flexibility and i
think that this kind of language like
moving a bit away from the group
formalism would allow us to talk about
say algorithmic invariants and things
like this i don't yet have any theory to
properly prove this but
it's something that i'm actively working
on
and i guess i would say yeah the only
question is would you still call this
geometric deep learning and in my
opinion the very creators of category
theory have said that category theory is
a direct extension of felix klein's
erlangen program so
since the founders of the field have
already made this connection i would
expect that
you know
it would be pretty applicable under a
geometric lens
so it seems to come back to it seems to
come back from both of your sides to
essentially graphs and and working
on on sort of graphs to capture on the
one side the sort of symmetries that
are that you either assume in the
problem or that you know or that you
want to impose on the other side on the
other side you know these computations
can may be well represented in in graphs
um what's what's so special about graphs
in in your estimations
is is there something
fundamental to it or is it just another
way you know we had
ben gertzel or so here and i asked him
the same question what's so special
about graphs and his argument was
essentially well it's not about graphs
it's simply a good representation of the
problem
that we can make efficient operations on
do you have a different opinion on that
is a graph something fundamental that we
should look more at than for example a
tensor
graphs are abstract models for systems
of relations or interactions i should
maybe specify
pairwise relations and interactions and
it happens that
a lot of physical or biological or
even social systems can be described at
least at some level of abstraction as as
a graph so that's why it is so popular
modeling tool in many fields you can
also obtain other structures such as
grids as particular cases i wouldn't
call it fundamental but it is a very
convenient and a very common i would say
ubiquitous
model now what i personally find
disturbing and we can talk about it
in more detail
later on is that
if you look at the different geometric
structures for gobble that we consider
in the book
whether it's euclidean spaces or many
phones
they all have the discrete counterparts
so you have a plane and they have you
can discretize it as a grid you know
manifold we can discretize it as a mesh
a graph is inherently discrete
and this is something that i find
disturbing
there is in fact an entire field that is
called network geometry that tries to
look at graphs as continuous objects so
for example certain types of graph that
look like social networks what is called
scale-free graphs
can be represented as nearest neighbor
graphs in some a little bit exotic space
with hyperbolic geometry
so if we take this analogy i think it is
very powerful
because now you can consider graphs as a
discretization of something continuous
and then
think for example of graph neural
networks
as certain types of diffusion processes
that are just discretized in a certain
way
and by making
potentially
possible different discretizations
you will get maybe better performing
architectures
one of the core dichotomies we talk
about on street talk is the apparent
dichotomy between discrete and
continuous and as yannick was saying
there are folks out there who um want
our knowledge substrate to be discreet
but still distributed we call them
sub-symbolic folks and and um this
network geometry is fascinating as well
because you're saying in some sense you
can think of there being some unknown
continuous geometry so so you're saying
there is no dichotomy
this is probably a little bit of visual
thinking as it happens with every model
so i would probably phrase it carefully
for some kinds of crafts you can make
this a continuous model
for others maybe not
fascinating well um on onto the subject
of vector spaces uh versus discrete you
know geometric deep learning is all
about making any domain
amenable to vector spaces right
and indeed artificial neural networks
but could these geometric principles be
applied to another form of machine
learning let's say discrete program
synthesis
certainly a very important question tim
and yeah thanks for asking that i think
that there are many ways in which
geometric deep learning is already at
least implicitly powering discrete
approaches such as program synthesis
because
there is a pretty big movement on these
so-called dual approaches where you
stick a
geometric deep learning architecture
within
a discrete tool that searches for the
best solution so for example in
combinatorial optimization a very
popular approach recently for neurally
solving mixed integer programs is to
like have your typical off-the-shelf
mip solver that selects variables to
optimize one at a time and you know with
these kinds of algorithms they're in
principle exponential time but if you're
lucky or knowledgeable enough about how
in what order you select these variables
you can actually solve the problem in
linear time which is something we would
like to strive towards and the exact way
in which we select these variables is a
bit of a black magic like humans have
come up with a few heuristics but they
don't always work and whenever you have
this kind of setting
as long as you're assuming that you're
naturally occurring data isn't always
throwing the worst possible cases or
adversarial cases at you you can usually
rely on some kind of modeling technique
for example a neural network to figure
out which decisions the model should be
taking so in this case for example for
mip solving deep minds recently
published a paper on this where you can
treat mip problems as bipartite graphs
where you have variables on one side and
the constraints on the other and you
link them together if a variable appears
in a constraint then they run a graph
neural network which as we just
discussed is one of the flagship models
in geometric deep learning over this
bipartite graph to decide which variable
the model should select next and you can
train this either as a separate kind of
supervised technique to learn some kind
of heuristic or you can learn it as part
of a more broader reinforcement learning
framework right where the reward you get
is how close you are to the solution or
something like this so
this is one
kind of clear way in which you can kind
of have this synergy between geometric
deep learning architectures and
solutions for for example program
synthesis
but i would just like to offer another
angle in which you can think of program
synthesis as nothing other than just one
more way to do language modeling right
because synthesizing a program is not
that different to synthesizing a
sentence maybe with a more stringent
check on syntax and and so forth
but you know any technique that
is applied to language modeling could in
principle be applied for program
synthesis and something that we will be
discussing i believe later during this
conversation
one of the flagship models of geometric
deep learning is indeed the transformer
which
we show in our book
and elucidate why it can be seen as a
very specific case of a graph neural
network
and that's one of the flagship models of
language modeling so
basically that's also one more way to to
unify like you know just because
the end output is discrete doesn't mean
that you cannot reason about it using
representations that are internally uh
vector vector based
francoise chalet
pointed out that there was this
dichotomy so you can embed discrete
information into a continuous
representation but the manifold needs to
be smooth it needs to be learnable it
needs to be interpolative in nature so i
thought that was why we have these
discrete program searches but then you
have this exponential blow up but maybe
that search space because it's
interpretive could be
found using stochastic gradient descent
if you embed the discrete information
into some kind of vector space but um
professor bronstein i wanted to throw it
back over to you i mean why is it taken
as a given that vector spaces are a good
thing because everything we're doing
here is embedding discrete information
into these euclidean vector spaces why
are we doing that
there are multiple reasons why vector
spaces are so popular in representation
learning
vectors are probably the most convenient
representation for both humans and
computers we can do for example
arithmetic operations with them like
addition or subtraction we can represent
them as arrays in the memory of the
computer
they are also continuous objects so it
is very easy to use continuous
optimization techniques in the back in
vector spaces it is difficult for
gumball to optimize a graph because it
is discrete and requires combinatorial
techniques but in a vector
representation i just have a bunch of
points that i can continuously move in a
high-dimensional space using standard
gradient-based techniques perhaps a more
nuanced question is what kind of
structures can be represented in a
vector space and a typical structure is
some notion of similarity or distance we
want that the vector representations
preserve the distances between let's say
original data points
and here we usually assume that the
vector space is equipped with the
standard euclidean metric or norm and we
have a problem from the domain of magic
geometry of representing one measuring
space in another
and unfortunately the general answer
here is negative you cannot exactly
embed an arbitrary metric in euclidean
space but there are of course some
results such as bogaine's
theorem
that for example provides
bounds on the matching distortion in
such cases
and in graph learning spaces with other
more exotic geometries such as
hyperbolic spaces have recently become
popular with for example papers of ben
chamberlain my colleague from twitter or
max nickel from facebook and uh you can
see that in certain types of graphs the
the number of neighbors grows
exponentially with the radius if you
look for example
at the number of friends of friends of
friends and so on in a social network
where you have this small world
phenomenon
you can see that it becomes
exponentially large with the growth of
the radius and now when you try to embed
this graph in euclidean space it will
become very crowded because in the
ingredient space the volume of the magic
ball grows polynomially with the radius
think of the two-dimensional case that
we all know from school the area of a
circle is by
radius squared right
the the volume of the ball is
exponential by the dimension so we
inevitably need to increase the
dimension of the embedding to make
space for these neighbors
in the hyperbolic space the situation is
very different because the volume grows
exponentially with the radius so it is
uh way more convenient uh
you to use these spaces for graph
embeddings and in fact recent papers
show that
to achieve the same error in embedding
of a graph in a hyperbolic space with
let's say 10 dimensions you would
require something like 100 dimensional
euclidean space
of course i should say that magics are
just one example of a structure so the
general answer to the question whether a
vector space is a good model for
representing data is as usual it depends
you mentioned you mentioned language
pittar and maybe to both of you
do you think there is a
do you think there is a geometry to
language itself i mean obviously we know
about embedding spaces and you know
close things
somehow share meaning and so on do you
think
do you think it goes beyond that because
like do you think there is an inherent
geometry to language itself and and sort
of the meaning of what we want to
transmit and and how that relates to
each other
what you probably
mentioned is the famous series of papers
from facebook where
unsupervised language translation can be
done by geometric alignment
of the latent spaces in my opinion it's
not something that describes geometry of
the language it probably describes in a
geometric way
some semantics of the world and even
though we have linguistically speaking
very different languages like let's say
english and chinese yet they describe
the same reality they describe the same
world where humans act so it is probably
reasonable to assume that the concepts
that they describe are similar and also
well there are some theories in
linguistics about certain universal
structures in languages that that are
shared even though the specifics are
different
i think it's interesting to look maybe
at non-human communications i i wouldn't
probably use the the term language
because it's a little bit loaded and
probably
some purists will be shocked by me
saying that for example whales
have a language but we are studying the
communication of spur whales so this is
a big international collaboration called
project and um i don't think that you
can really model
the
concepts that whales need to describe
and to deal with
in the same way as we humans do so maybe
a silly example we can say in human
languages and probably
it applies to every language we can
express a concept that something got wet
i don't think that a whale would even
understand what it means by
being wet because
the whale always lives in water i would
add to that maybe a slightly different
view of geometry but you know it's all
about the question of
how far are you willing to go and still
call it geometry based on our
proto book at least i tend to think of
graph structures also as a form of
geometry even though it's a bit more
abstract
and within language
people might not always agree what this
structure is like but i think we can be
fairly certain that there are explicit
links between individual words as in
when you use them in different forms
syntax trees or just one word precedes
another and so on and so forth
and you know while we may not be
necessarily able to easily say what is
the
geometric significance of one word what
we can look at is what is the local
geometry of the words that you tend to
use around it
and i mean this kind of principle has
been used all over the place
that has then been extended to graph
structured observations generally with
models like deep walk and node to vect
basically the same idea treat a node's
representation as everything that's
around it basically the reason why i
think that analyzing this local topology
of how words are used with each other is
very powerful
i've reinforced that recently precisely
because of the fact i've been
delving into category theory because in
category theory your nodes are basically
atoms you're not allowed to look inside
them you assume they're this undivisible
unit of information and everything you
can conclude about the atoms comes from
the arrows between them so
using this very simple concept with a
few additional constraints like
compositionality you can for example
tell me what are all the elements of a
set
even though you've abstracted that set
to a single point just by analyzing the
arrows between all sets you can tell me
what are all the elements inside the set
so thinking about this i i do believe
that it is possible to reason about
geometric you know word to vect for
example does this with the assumption
that the structure of the
are we approaching this at the right
level though because
people have said for quite a long time
that there's a difference between syntax
and semantics and you could look at the
geometrical structure of spoken language
or for example you could look at the
topology of the connections in your
brain the topology of of connect you
know reference frames in your brain is
how you actually have learned concepts
would looking at the topology of spoken
language tell you enough about abstract
categories
that's a good question um
i think that
if
that kind of information is necessary
like if the atoms by themselves won't
tell you everything
one thing that we actually very commonly
do in graph representation learning is
assume this sort of hierarchical
approach where you have like the ground
level with your actual individual notes
and then you come up with some kind of
additional hierarchy that tells you
either something about intermediate
topologies in a graph
or intermediate structures that you care
about in this graph or any abstract
concepts you might have extracted and
then there's additional links being
drawn between these to kind of reinforce
the
the knowledge that the graph net can
capture so i think if you have knowledge
of some abstract concepts that are
relevant for your particular task
you can attach them as additional pieces
of information to this topology
of course the more exciting part is
could we maybe discover them
automatically but that is something that
i don't think is potentially in scope
for this question when uh human
interpreters need to translate from one
one language to another they often need
to deal with uh different sentence
structures i think turkish is actually
an extreme example where
the order of words is completely
reversed
it implies that you need probably to
hold well in computer science terms some
kind of a buffer in your brain
uh before you can make the translation
to another language so it definitely
imposes certain biological network
structure in the brain another
interesting observation that i read
somewhere about
the
the way that people remember certain
facts
when they speak a certain language so
and the particular example that was
given is a person can remember a
perpetrator of a crime
and then
give testimony in court
and
the reason is that in some languages it
is more common to use impersonal
pronouns
and the personal phrases so you can say
for example the object was broken and in
some languages you would say that
somebody broke
the object so it appeared that languages
were of these more impersonal
constructions people speaking these
languages
i have her time to remember the
perpetrator so the the language probably
imposes a lot about the the way that we
perceive world but it is probably not
studied sufficiently
but that there may be some fuzzy graph
isomorphisms though between the
languages it i think there's something
really magic about graphs i think that's
what we're getting into because your
your lecture series inspired me actually
uh professor bronstein where you were
talking about all the different
applications of graphs but um something
that a lot of our guests talk about are
knowledge graphs right and expert
systems and the knowledge acquisition
bottleneck were the cause of the abject
failure
of good old-fashioned ai or symbolic ai
systems in the 1980s and many hybrid or
neurosymbolic folks today are still
arguing that we need to have a discrete
knowledge graph um either human designed
or learned or evolved or emerged or some
combination of those
things i just said depending on who you
talk to now critically many gopher
people think that most knowledge we have
is acquired through reasoning not
learning right which is really really
interesting so by reasoning i mean
extrapolating new knowledge from
existing knowledge um it feels like
graph neural networks could at least be
part of the solution here and in your
lecture series you you mentioned the
work by kramner which was explainable
gnns where they use some kind of
symbolic regression to to get a symbolic
model from a graph neural network so do
you think there's some really cool work
we can do here
there is a little bit of divide in in
graph learning literature so people
working on graph neural networks and
working on knowledge graphs even though
at least in principle the methods are
similar for example you typically do
some form of embedding of the nodes of
the graph
somehow these are distinct communities
probably historically they they evolved
in different fields yeah so the paper of
canvas this is really interesting
because they use crafts to model
physical systems for example
and body problem when they have
particles that interact
you can describe these interactions as
as a graph
and you can use a standard generic
message passing functions
to to model the interactions now the
step forward that they do is they
replace these genetic message passing
functions
with symbolic equations
and not only that this allows to
generalize better but you also have an
interpretable system you can recover
from your data
the laws of motion right and if you
think of how much time it they took
historically to people like johannes
kepler for example he spent his entire
life
on analyzing astronomical observations
to derive a law that now
bears his name
that describes the elliptic orbits of
planets
nowadays with these methods you can
probably do it in a matter of seconds or
maybe minutes
i think the the point that particularly
caught my attention and what you asked
tim was this interplay between graphs
and reasoning and extrapolation how that
supports knowledge
now when it comes to how critical is
this going to be
it depends on the environment in which
you put your agent like is it a closed
environment or is it an open-ended
environment where new information and
new knowledge can come in in principle
at any time
this like basically do you want to build
a neural scientist or do you just want
to build a neural exploiter that like
takes all the information available
right now and then draws conclusions
based on that
so if the system is closed world you'll
probably be able to get away without
like very explicit reasoning especially
if you have tons of data because we've
seen time and time again that large
scale models can kind of pick up on
these regularities if they've seen it
often enough
but
if i give you a solution
that involves stacking for example n
objects and now i ask you to do the same
kind of reasoning with two times n
objects the way in which we optimize
neural networks at least today is
typically going to completely fall on
its back when you when you do something
like this
so if you truly want to take whatever
regularities you have come across in the
the world of the training data and hope
to at least
reasonably gracefully apply them to new
kinds of rules
that that come in the future
um
then you probably want your model to
extrapolate to a certain extent and
that for this at least my ongoing
algorithmic reasoning research
algorithms are a very natural
area to study under this lens because
they trivially extrapolate you write an
algorithm that does a particular thing
on a set of n nodes you can be you can
usually mathematically prove that it's
going to do the same thing
equally properly maybe a bit more slowly
if you give it two times n nodes right
this kind of guarantee typically doesn't
come that easily with neural networks
and we found that you have to very
carefully massage the way you train them
the kinds of data you feed to them the
kinds of inductive biases you feed into
them
in order to get them to do something
like this so if extrapolation is
something you truly need then you know i
think for artificial general
intelligence we're going to want to have
at least some degree of extrapolation as
new information will become available to
our neural scientists just as you follow
the era of time
um basically
for for doing something like this graph
neural networks have arisen as a very
attractive primitive because there's
been a few really exciting theoretical
results coming out in recent years
saying that the operations of a graph
neural network align really really well
with dynamic programming algorithms and
dynamic programming is a very standard
computational primitive
using which you can express most
polynomial time heuristics so
essentially that's a really good
you know that's a really
good piece of mind result the
unfortunate side of it is that it's a
best-case result right so you can set
the weights of a neural network of a
graph neural network to mimic a dynamic
programming algorithm more efficiently
or with smaller sample complexity
but you know there's still a big problem
of how do i learn it in a way that it
still works when i double the size of my
input and
that is in a way what algorithmic
reasoning has been largely about like
we're trying to make that happen it's
not easy this if you throw the vanilla
graph neural network and just input
output pairs of an algorithm it will
learn to fit them in distribution the
moment you give like ask it to sort in a
rate it's twice as big it's going to
completely collapse so
this is the number one thing that the
neurosymbolic people say they say neural
networks they don't extrapolate they
only interpolate you know it just it
it's it's a continuous geometric model
learns point by point transforms the
data onto some continuous smooth
learnable manifold you interpolate
between the data points you want to have
a smooth you want to have a dense
sampling of your data but you're talking
about dynamic programming problems these
are discrete problems that the structure
is discontinuous like how could you
possibly learn that within your network
well
the dynamic programming algorithm
could be could have a discontinuous
component to it
for example if you're searching for
shortest paths at some point you will
take an arg max over all of your
neighbors computed distances and use
that to decide what the path is
but before you come to the arg max part
there is usually some fairly smooth
function being computed actually so in
the case of shortest path computations
you know bellman ford or something like
this you say something very simple like
i have a value d of s in every single
one of my nodes which is initially
infinity everywhere and 0 in the source
vertex and then at every point i say
the distance of my particular node is
the minimum
of all the distances
of my neighbors plus the edge weight
right and this kind of function is
generally more graceful than than taking
an argmax and
you can also think of for example if you
have to compute expected values or
something like this using dynamic
programming that's also one example
where actually summing is what you need
to do across all of your neighbors or
something like this so yeah it is true
that like
across individual steps you may be doing
like discrete optimization steps
but usually it's propelled by some kind
of continuous computation under the hood
so that's the part that the graph neural
network actually simulates and then the
part which does the arg max would be
some kind of classifier that you stitch
on top of that so
in principle it's not
yeah it's not too challenging to massage
it into a neural network framework so
one of the i think one of you mentioned
this before brought up transformers and
um
you know in recent years we've had i
think about 10 different papers saying
transformers are something there is
transformers or rnns
transformers are hopfield networks and
and and also transformers are or graph
neural networks or compute some kind of
graph neural networks can you maybe
speak a bit to that or transformers
specifically graph neural networks or
are they just so general that you can
also formulate a graph problem in terms
of a of a transformer
okay
that's that's a very good question um i
would start off by saying
like i don't want to start this
discussion just by saying yes
transformers or graphic neural networks
this is why end of story because i feel
like you know that doesn't touch upon
the whole picture so let's let's look at
this from a natural language processing
angle which is how most people have come
to know about transformers so
imagine that you have a task which is
specified on a sentence
and
you want to exploit the fact that words
in a sentence interact right it's not
just a bag of words there is there's
some interesting structure inside this
bunch of words that you might want to
exploit when we were using recurrent
neural networks we assumed that the
structure between the words was a line
graph so basically
every word
is preceding another word and so on and
so forth and you kind of just linearly
process them with the model like lstm or
something
but
you know basically line graphs as we
know are not the way language is
actually structured there can be super
long range interactions inside language
so subjects and objects in the same
sentence could appear miles away from
each other so using the line graph is
not the most optimal way of getting that
information in the fastest possible in
the fastest possible way
so
okay there's clearly some kind of
non-trivial graph structure what is it
well
it turns out that people cannot really
agree what this optimal graph structure
is and it may well be task dependent
actually so just consider syntax trees
for example like there's not always a
unique way of decomposing a sentence
into a syntax tree and the exact kind of
tree you might wish to use to represent
the sentence may be different depending
on what is the actual thing that you're
solving
so okay we have a situation where we
know that there's some connectivity
between the words but we don't know what
that connectivity is so in graph
representation learning what we
typically do when we don't know the
graph as long as the number of objects
is not huge is to assume a complete
graph and let the graph neural network
figure out by itself what the important
connections are
and if i now stitch an attentional
message passing mechanism onto this
graph neural network
i have effectively rederived the
transformer model equation without ever
like using this
specific transformer lingo so from this
kind of angle the fact that it's a model
that operates over a complete graph of
uh individual words
in a way that you know once you've put
all the embeddings to them is
permutation equivariant this describes
the central equations of self-attention
that the transformer uses the the part
which i think causes a bit of a divide
here
is the fact that transformers like the
model that was originally presented are
not just the equations of a transformer
they're also the positional embeddings
of a transformer and that's the part
that sort of gives it a bit more of a
sentential structure
well actually if you look at these sine
and cosine waves that get attached to
the individual words in an input to a
transformer you will see that you can
you can actually derive a pretty good
connection between them and the discrete
fourier transform which actually turn
out to be the eigenvectors of a graph
laplacian for a line graph so
essentially these positional embeddings
are hinting to the model that you are
the descent that these words in a
sentence are arranged in a particular
way and you can use that information but
because it's fed in as features the
model doesn't have to use any of that
information like sometimes bag of words
is the right thing to do for example
right so essentially the transformer has
a bit of a light hint that there's a
sentential structure in there in the
form of a line graph
but
you know the the model itself is a
permutation equivalent model over a
complete graph and from our lens of the
geometric deep learning it is
effectively a special case of an
attentional gnn now i think this
positional embedding aspect is a super
important one and it could hint to how
we might extend these transformers from
sentences to more general structures and
i think michael you might have a lot
more thoughts on that than i do so maybe
you can say a bit about that
yeah so positional encoding has been
done for graphs as well as pattern
mentioned in case of a graph we can
straightforwardly generalize this sine
or cosine
positional coordinates that are used in
transformers using the eigenvectors of
the laplacian there are other techniques
you can actually
show that you can make the message
passing type neural network strictly
more powerful than traditional message
passing the equivalent vice versa lemon
graphisomorphism test
by using a special kind of structure
aware
positional encoding
for example if you can count
substructures of the graph such as
cycles or rings
and so on and this way you have a
message passing algorithm that that
is specialized to the particular
position in the graph and um can for
example detect structures that the
traditional message passing cannot
detect
so it is at least not
less powerful than the vice very element
algorithm and we can actually show
examples on which vice versa algorithm
or traditional message passing fails
whereas this kind of approach succeeds
so
the thing i've always wondered about
transformers networks
are the position tokens i really don't
like them and i want them to go away
because it feels very impure doesn't it
i think what we really want to learn is
some kind of higher order structure
in the language and it kind of felt like
we
were using the position tokens to cheat
a little bit so what i'm trying to get
across here is that i think the position
of a token in an utterance should be
invariant i mean clearly in different
languages the tokens are in different
places in turkish the order is
completely reversed and i would like to
think that our internal language
representation ignores the
transmission arrangement right given the
particular language and the constraint
that we only communicate sequential
streams of words
however i do appreciate what michael is
saying above that the position encodings
can actually encode
more powerful structures like cycles and
rings the key question is do we actually
need to have these structures
in natural language i don't agree that
you want to get rid of them so
positional encoding it's a kind of
combination of two worlds right so if
you consider a graph
then you're completely agnostic to the
ordering of the nodes this is one of the
really key characteristics of graphs and
sets more generally that you don't have
the ordering of the nodes
the situations and the problems where
transformers are applied you actually do
have an order but you use the graph as a
better described
to model different long-distance
relations between different uh tokens or
words in a sentence
so you want to incorporate this prior
knowledge that these nodes are not
in arbitrary order that they have some
sentence order and
this principle applied more generally
you can use positional encoding to tell
message passing not to apply exactly the
same function everywhere on the graph
but to make it specialized for different
portions of the graphs or at least make
it a possibility and then
the
the training will
decide whether to use this information
or not or in which way
it's strange because i don't know
whether the order is just a function of
the communication medium so we transmit
the tokens in a sequence and could we
then represent them in our brains in a
completely different domain where the
sequence is no longer relevant well
actually a lot of neuroscientists think
that our brain is a prediction machine
and it's a sequence prediction machine
so the sequence is kind of fundamentally
important
yeah it's and it's also a function of
the specific language that you use and
as we discussed before there are
languages which convey the same meaning
with a different sentence structure i
want to get a little bit into
what you said about
essentially what we're doing with these
positional encodings is we hint we hint
to the model that there is something
here which is a big break from sort of
the old approach let's say of an lstm to
say this is the structure right um so
with with the the world of geometric
deep learning i often have the feeling
people talk about they talk about you
know symmetries and we need to exploit
these symmetries that are present in the
world and
there's almost to me two different
groups of these symmetries so one group
is
maybe you would call them like exact
symmetries or something like this when i
think about alpha fold and i think about
like a protein it doesn't i don't care
which side is up right like the protein
is the same the same protein and there's
no reason to prefer any direction over
any other direction however if i think
of like
because people have made this argument
for cnns for example they say well a cnn
is a good architecture because it's
translation and variant right and
essentially if we want to do object
recognition or image classification
translation invariance is like a given
but but it's not right it's not a given
the pictures that we feed to these
algorithms most often the object is in
the middle most often you know it's kind
of upright like the sky is on top and
the floor yes i can hold my camera like
this but i don't right so it it seems to
be it seems to be
in many cases better to not put the
symmetries in there until we're like
really really really really sure that
these are actual symmetries because with
more data it seems the model that does
not have the prior inside becomes
better than the model that does have the
prior inside if that prior doesn't
exactly match the world is
do you think that's a fair
characterization of for example why
transformers with large data all of a
sudden beat
classic cnn models or come close to them
i think it's it's always this question
of the trade-off between how much your
your model and uh how much you're
learning i remember when i was a student
there was this maxim that that machine
learning is always the second best
solution and maybe nowadays with
deep learning showing some remarkable
set of successes i'm probably less
confident in this statement but it's
probably still quite true that the more
you know about your problem the better
chances that that machine learning will
will work for it to me it makes sense uh
to model as much as possible and learn
what is hard or impossible to to model
and in practice of course there is a
spectrum of possibilities of how much of
these prior assumptions are hardwired
into the architecture and usually it's a
trade of
between the for example computational
complexity availability of the data
also hardware friendliness and if you
think of what happened in computer
vision it's probably a good illustration
that that convolutional networks have
translational environs for example as
you mentioned but in many problems you
might benefit from other symmetries such
as rotations again depends on the
application but imagine that you want to
recognize i don't know traffic signs
when you can also tilt your car and you
may ask why in these applications as
well cnns um
are still so popular and probably one of
the reasons is that they map very well
to the single instruction multiple data
type of hardware architectures that gpus
offer and you can compensate for
explicitly not accounting for rotational
symmetry with data augmentation
and more complex architectures and
larger training sets and this is exactly
what happened
a decade ago with this convergence of
three trends the availability of compute
power right the gpus
algorithms that map well to these
computational architectures and these
happen to be convolutional networks and
also very large uh data sets that you
can train these architectures on such as
imagenet
so
many of the the choices that
become popular in the literature are
maybe not necessarily
theoretically the best ones so i think
in in hardware design there is this
phenomenon that is called the hardware
lottery
when it's not necessarily the best
algorithm and the best hardware
that solves the problem it's just
some lucky coincidence and their happy
marriage that makes them successful
we keep raising this point about how
transformers can be seen in special case
of attentional gnns but you know the
status quo is that people will use
transformers for
very many tasks nowadays and you know
there may well be a good argument for
considering them in this completely
separate light and one possible you know
explanation or justification for this is
the hardware lottery because
yes sure transformers perform
permutation equivalent operations over a
complete graph but they do so in a way
that is very very highly amenable to the
kind of matrix multiplication routines
that we can support very efficiently on
gpus nowadays so basically they can be
seen as the graph neural network that
has won the current hardware lottery
even in cases where maybe it will make
more sense to consider a more
constrained graph especially if you have
low data environments or something like
this
the the potential you know overheads of
running a full graph neural network
solution with message passing which
given its extremely sparse nature
doesn't align that well with gpus and
tpus nowadays sometimes just using a
complete graph neural network is the
more economical option when you take all
factors into account and that's and also
the fact that they use an attention
mechanism which is
kind of a middle ground between
a simple diffusion process on a graph
which would just kind of average things
together based on the topology and the
full-on message passing where you
actually compute a full-on vector
message to be sent across the edges like
it strikes a nice balance of scalability
and still being able to represent
a lot of functions of interest
especially when your inputs are just
word tokens right so like you know in a
way it's a gnn that strikes a very nice
sweet spot and that's probably the
reason why it's it's become so
it's become so popular in current times
now of course there is a chance that
hardware and there's actually a pretty
high probability that hardware will
catch up to the trends in graph
representation learning and we will
start to see a bit more graph oriented
hardware but at least for the time being
yeah there's a bit of a combination of
what's theoretically making the most
sense for your problem and what the
hardware that you have right now will
support
the most easily
yeah there is a british startup i think
they they have reached recently a
unicorn status called graphcore and you
can already hear from the name of the
company that there is a graph inside
they try to develop hardware that goes
beyond the traditional paragraphs yeah
i'm really interested in the hardware
lottery we had we had sarah hooker on
massive shout out to sarah and yannick
made a video on the hardware lottery
paper as well um
i mean i'd push back a little bit i
think there's also a bit of an
optimization and an algorithmic lottery
going on i think there's something very
very interesting about stochastic
gradient descent and the kind of data
that we're working with but but this
actually gets to my next question which
is about why exactly geometry is a good
prior and how principled it is so it
seems like these geometric prizes are
principled and they have utility because
they are low-level primitives right
they're ubiquitous and natural data but
why exactly is it a principled approach
to start with things we know which is to
say geometric primitives and to work
upwards from there you know what would
it look like if we went top down instead
and what makes a good prior i mean one
way to think about it is the actual
function space um that you're searching
through you know this hypothesis space
it's not just about being able to find
the function easily in that space or the
simplicity of the function you find
charlay would say it's the information
conversion ratio of that function so you
know can you use this function that you
found to convert a very small piece of
information and experience space into
new knowledge or a new ability but
how do you find these these functions
one of the points that we try to make
in the book is
the separation between the domain
and the group that you assume on the
domain the symmetry group
so um you might have the same domain
like two-dimensional grid or or
two-dimensional plane
and for example the translation group or
the group of rotations and translations
or the group of rigid motions that also
include
reflections so these are
completely separate
notions
and which one to choose
depends on the problem the choice of the
domain really comes from the structure
of your data so if your data comes as an
image then of course you use a grid to
represent it as the choice of the domain
now which symmetry group to use is a
more subtle point
and it really depends on what you are
trying to achieve you can think of for
example uh traffic sign recognition when
the car drives on the road
usually the the the signs will have
certain orientation it's very unlikely
that you will
see it upside down so the really the
only
in variance or the only kind of symmetry
you have is translation so cnn's in this
case would work perfectly well so if for
example you have histopathological
samples so you have a slice of tissue
that you need to put under the
microscope so
you can naturally flip the glass you
don't know how it is oriented so
reflections are also initial
transformation so
in the traffic size of course this is
not physical unless you see your sign in
the back mirror but
in this histopathology example
it is a natural transformation so the
choice of the symmetry group and what
makes a good geometric prior is really
dictated by the specific problem
it's it's often very hard though to
actually choose because we often don't
really know
right coming back to what i said before
if we if we actually hit the group
correctly and in fact um we've we've
sort of seen the
the more successful approach and this
might be hardware specific but but it
seems the more successful approach is
often to actually make data
augmentations with respect to what we
assume are symmetries so to you know i i
think of all the the color distortions
that we do to images we rotate them a
bit we we rescale them and so on it
would be definitely possible to build
architectures that are just invariant to
those things however it seems to be a
more successful approach in practice to
put this all into the into the data
augmentations how do you
what's your take on
on that
how do we choose between putting prior
knowledge into augmentations versus
putting prior knowledge into the
architecture
it's not a binary choice it's not either
your model or your augment with data
one of the key principles that we also
emphasize in the book is that of course
this uh perfect environs or equivalence
is a wishful thinking in many cases you
you want to get the property that
we call geometric stability you have
some transformation that
is approximately a group or imagine that
you have a video where two objects are
moving let's say one car moves left and
another car moves right so there is no
global translation that describes
the relation between the two frames in
this video
the geometric stability principle tells
you that
if you are close enough to
to an element of the group if you can
describe this transformation as an
approximate translation
then you will be approximately in right
or approximately equivalent and this is
actually what happens in cnn so this was
shown by johan
and they use this motivation to explain
why convolutional and neural networks
are so powerful so roughly speaking if i
don't have a translation but for example
if i have a omnis digit and you have
different styles of the digits you can
think of them as warpings of some
canonical digit so in this case even
though it's not described as a
translation and the neural network will
not be environed or equivalent to this
kind of transformation it will be stable
under these transformations and that's
why
data augmentation works in in some sense
that you're extending your environments
or equivalence class to approximate in
variance and active
taco also had a few interesting things
to say about data augmentations versus
um building the
inductive prize into the model this is
taco
is your preference towards
i mean i assume it is towards um
creating inductive priors in the
architecture around geometry instead of
um data augmentation
oh that's a good question um
i think it depends on the uh uh on the
problem like ins if
in some cases you don't have a choice so
graphs are a great example the group of
permutations is n factorial elements if
n is large you have a thousand nodes
you're never ever going to be able to
exhaustively sample that that group and
so it's better to just build it and and
that's also why no graph neural net uh
doesn't respect the symmetry nobody's
suggesting you should do that by data
augmentation with some other cases
um
it is uh
you know somewhat possible to sample
a reasonably dense grid of
transformations your group um
and uh indeed
you know the augmentation is turning out
to be very important in in uh
unsupervised learning and
self-supervised learning uh techniques
so i am actually
uh
i look very positively to towards that i
don't think it's uh it's wrong to to put
in this knowledge using data
augmentation but in some cases like
let's say when you're on classifying
medical data like cells in in a dish
histopathology images or something you
just know for sure there's translation
and rotation symmetries the cells don't
have a natural orientation
and in those cases i do think it makes
sense to build it into the architecture
for
for the simple reason that
if you build it into the architecture
you're guaranteed that the network will
be equivariant not just at the training
data
but also at the test data so you never
have that the network would make the
correct classification for your test
data when you have it in one orientation
but when you rotate it it suddenly does
something different
which can happen if
uh even when uh
you present your training images in all
possible orientations
uh so so i think for that reason um
equivariance does tend to work better in
in those cases where there's an exact
symmetry in the data we have actually
demonstrated that empirically where for
example in a in a medical imaging
problem of uh detecting lung nodules in
three-dimensional ct scans
we we started off
with a convolutional network
uh with the data augmentation pipeline
was completely tuned with state of the
art method at the time
and we simply replaced all the
convolutions by group convolutions that
respect the rotational symmetries as
well as the translations and we get a
very significant uh improvement in
performance so that goes to show that
in practice often data augmentation
can't get you all the way so for the
cases where there's an exact symmetry i
thought or where the group of symmetries
is very large i think um
uh building it into the network is the
way to go for the foreseeable future
uh but there are many cases where uh
where augmentation is also uh uh well
where implementation is the way to go
that's that's here
i'm really interested in this notion
that could these symmetries actually be
harmful i mean i know zhuan for example
spoke about the three sources of error
of machine learning models and one of
them is the approximation error and
normally when we get signals they come
to us in a contrived form don't know
they they might uh be projected onto a
planar manifold and
um
you know the sky is always up for
example does it really help us having
these geometric uh symmetries as
primitives in the model
yeah that's a that's a good question
uh the the simple answer is if your
problem doesn't have the exact symmetry
then at least in the limit of having
infinite data uh
building in equivariance is going to be
harmful and it's better to to learn the
true structure of of the data this
approximate symmetry which you should be
able to pick up from the from the data
alone
um so that that's one thing that that
still means in a low data regime uh it
can be very useful even when the
symmetries is approximate
um but i would also say that sometimes
in machine learning
the we have a tendency to
put too much faith into the
evaluation metrics and data sets so we
say we want to solve computer vision and
what we mean is we want to get a high
score on imagenet and certainly it's
true in imagenet the images tend to
appear in upright position and then and
they are photographed by by humans so
the key objects are kind of in the
center most of the time etc so these are
biases that you could exploit
and you might stop yourself from
exploiting them
uh if you build in the the the symmetry
but
that that's only a problem if you if you
sort of uh put on your blinders and you
say imagenet uh accuracy is the only
thing that counts right you might very
well think if you want to to build a
very general uh vision engine it is
useful that it still works if suddenly
uh the robot falls over and has to look
at the world upside down uh so
so the symmetry can still be there in
principle even if it's not there in
practice in your your data set
um and you know then there's uh there's
maybe a robustness versus computational
efficiency trade-off so
yes maybe you're willing to acknowledge
if your robot falls over you still want
it to work so you want that rotation
equivalence but then again if we don't
have to process the images upside down
in the 99 of cases
where the images are upright
uh we gain some computational efficiency
so there's a trade-off there uh and uh
yeah there i don't think there's a right
or wrong answer uh it's it's it's
something you have to look at on a
case-by-case basis when i put this to
professor bronstein as well he also said
that you folks were looking at trying to
remember how he described it i think he
said there was a kind of
representational stability which allowed
for approximate symmetries so it's not
necessarily that you're going for these
precise symmetries you're actually
looking for a little um sort of margin
of robustness going to moving into
approximate symmetries that you might
not have explicitly captured
i i agree i think that's also a very
important uh yeah philosophy and
approach to take the group think of it
as somehow embedded in a larger group
like most of the
geometrical symmetries that we think
about are somehow a subgroup of
diffiomorphisms
uh and then if you if you say i don't
want invariants with or equivariance but
some kind of stability or smoothness to
elements in the group plus small
diffiomorphisms for instance
uh you uh yeah you you might get some of
the generalization benefit without
unduly uh
limiting the capacity of your of your
model
is there a hope though that we can we
can get
this approx because i see i see your
point i think is that
or one of one of the points is i think
is that if we program like a symmetry
into the architecture it will be rather
fixed right we make an architecture
translation invariant it's it's going to
be fully translation invariant are there
good ways to bring approximate
invariances into the space of the
architectures that we work with yeah i
mean i have a very quick answer and
maybe not too satisfying but
one very simple one if you think of
neural network blocks as like components
that implement different symmetries and
then you think of like a calculus of
these blocks as you know building your
deep learning architecture
one very simple representational tool
that we can use to
allow the model to use the symmetry but
also not use the symmetry is the skip
connection so essentially
you could have a model that processes
for example your graph data using a
particular connectivity structure that
you want to be invariant to
and you can also use say a transformer
that processes things in a completely
permutation invariant way over the
complete graph
and you can just shortcut the results of
one model over the other model if you
want to give also the model the choice
to ignore the previous one so maybe not
a very you know
a detailed and satisfying answer but
that's one simple way in which we could
do something like this and in some of
our more recent algorithmic reasoning
blueprint papers we do exactly this
because
one very important thing that we're
trying to solve is
apply classical algorithms to problems
that would need them but the data is
super rich and it's really hard to you
know massage it into the abstractified
form that the algorithm needs for
example you want to find shortest paths
in a road network a real world road
network you cannot just take all the
complexity of changing weather
conditions changing diffusion patterns
on the on the roads and the roadblocks
and all these kinds of things and turn
that into this obstructified graph with
exactly one scalar for each edge so you
can apply dijkstra or something like
this like it's just not feasible without
losing a ton of information so what
we're doing here is we make this
high-dimensional neural network
component that simulates the effects of
dijkstra but we're also mindful of the
fact that
to compute say the expected travel time
there's more factors at play than just
the output of a shortest path algorithm
right there could well also be some
flow related elements maybe just some
elements related to the current time of
day human psychology what not right so
we start off by assuming the algorithm
does not give the complete picture in
this high dimensional noisy
world so we always as default as part of
our architecture incorporate a skip
connection from just you know a raw
neural network encoder over the
algorithm so in case there's any model
free information that you want to
extract without looking at what the
algorithm tells you you can do that so
maybe i don't know yannick if that
answers your question about approximate
symmetries but that's that's the kind of
the vibe i got when i heard the question
i mean that's a very that's very
practical
answer for sure that you know you can
actually get out there it even opens the
possibility to you know having maybe
multiple
kinds of skip connections and what not
you know having
dividing up your symmetries into
individual blocks that are run in
parallel maybe
um but that brings me to maybe another
thing we've we've talked about you know
there are symmetries you want to
incorporate them into your problem and
so on and we've also talked about the
symbolic regression beforehand to maybe
parse out symmetries of the underlying
problem what are the current best
approaches if we don't know the
symmetries
so we have a bunch of data we suspect
there must be some kind of symmetries at
play because they're usually are in the
world right
and they
if we knew them we could describe our
problems in very compact forms and solve
them very efficiently but we don't often
know
so
what are the current state of the art
when i don't know the symmetries how do
i discover what group structure is at
play in a particular problem i don't
think that there is a single approach
that solves this problem
in a satisfactory manner and one of the
reasons why because the problem is
ambiguous so maybe an example think of
objects mostly translate horizontally
but you also have a little bit of
vertical translation
what is the right
symmetry structure to model is it a
one-dimensional translation group or a
two-dimensional translation group do we
want to absorb the vertical the slight
vertical motions
as
the noise and deal with it as a data
augmentation or you want to describe it
in the structure of the group that you
discover
so there is no single answer
so it's you cannot say that one is
correct and another one is wrong
yeah i think and this was kind of where
i was going with the question of how how
principled are the symmetries and the
symmetries seem to be hierarchical just
in the same way that geometries are
hierarchical you were saying that for
example the um projective
geometry is kind of subsumes euclidean
geometry but um i had a little thought
experiment so imagine i gave you a large
data set produced by a recursive fractal
pattern now nature is full of fractals
trees rivers coastlines mountains clouds
seashells and even hurricanes so let's
say i i didn't tell you the simple rule
which produced this pattern now what
kind of regularities would you look for
in the model that you built i mean it
seems obvious that there would be an
expanding scale symmetry which might
resemble the original rule but it feels
like there'd be plenty of other emergent
abstract symmetries which are not
obviously related to the simple rule
which produced the pattern i mean yanni
was just saying when you look at
computer vision you see a kind of um
regularity or invariance to color shifts
for example so are fractals are good
analogy for physical reality and should
we be looking for the low-level
primitive regularities which i think
you're advocating for or should we be
looking at more abstract emergent
symmetries which appear
in the 90s there was a famous paper by
michael barsley on fractal coding
and they claimed really unbelievable
compression ratios for natural images
and the way it worked was to try to
reassemble the image from parts of
itself
and possibly of course you can take
parts and subject them to some geometric
transformation so roughly if you have a
page of pixels uh you can approximate it
as another page taken from somewhere
else in the image that you translate
rotate and scale
and then the image was represented as an
operator that makes such a decomposition
and this operator was constructed in a
special way to be contractive and then
they used the banana fixed point theorem
that you can apply this operator to any
image so you can start with the noise
for example completely random image
and
you have the target image emerge after a
few iterations so that that this
iterative scheme will converge to the
fixed point of the operator which is the
image itself and it was actually
used in the industry uh well microsoft
and carter encyclopedia
i don't know
how many viewers are old enough to
remember it
but the main issue was it was the
difficulty to build such operations the
compression was very asymmetric it was
very easy to decode you just take any
image and
apply this operator multiple times but
it was really very hard to encode it in
fact some of these constructions that
showed remarkable compression ratios
were constructed semi by hand i should
say that in more recent times in
computer vision for example the group of
mikhail irani from the weizmann
institute in israel
use similar ideas for super resolution
and image denoising where your you can
build the clean or higher resolution
image from bits and pieces of the image
itself so it's a single image denoising
or super resolution and what you do is
you try to
use
similarities across different positions
and scales
that's absolutely fascinating i mean
it it
i spend a lot of time thinking about
this because you know my intuition is
that deep learning works quite well
because of these strict structural
limitations of the data which is
produced by our physical world right and
would you say that physical reality is
highly dimensional
or not um if it's highly dimensional is
it because it emerged from a simple set
of rules or relations like we were just
talking about because because i think
what you're arguing for is that it could
be collapsible in some sense
probably the term dimension is a bit
frivolously used here but
i would say that it's
probably fair to say that at some scale
many physical systems can be described
with a small number of degrees of
freedom parameters that that
captured the system
and as we are talking i'm sitting in a
room i'm surrounded by probably a
quadrillion of gas molecules in the air
that fly through the room and collide
with each other and the walls of the
room so at
the microscopic level the dimension is
very high so it's absolutely intractable
if we were to model each molecule and
how it collides i will have a huge
number of degrees of freedom and uh yet
if we zoom out we can model this system
statistically and that's exactly the
main idea of thermodynamics and
statistical mechanics
and this macroscopic system
is surprisingly simple it can be
described by just a few parameters such
as temperature
and
the example fractals that you brought up
before
essentially show that you can create
very complex patterns with very simple
rules that are applied locally
in a repeated way
this might be a question for you peter
the geometric blueprint works
brilliantly in the ideal world where we
can compute all of the possible group
actions but
graph neural networks for example you
know the permutation group is factorial
in size which means we need to rely on
heuristics like graph convolutions so um
how much better would graph neural
networks be if we could compute all of
the permutations i mean are you happy
with these heuristics in general
so that is a very good question and yes
so so let's just start from stating the
obvious if you want to
explicitly express every possible
operation that properly commutes with
the graph structure and in that sense is
a graph convolution
you would not be able to represent that
properly as a neural network operation
because you have to store in principle a
vector for every single element of the
permutation group so unless your graph
is super tiny that is just not going to
work so
on one hand this is a potentially
annoying result on another hand it is
also exciting because we know that even
though we ended up like doing most of
our graphic neural network research in
this very restricted regime of
i'm going to define a permutation
invariant function over my immediate
neighbors and that will as a result
translate into a permutation equivalent
function over the whole graph
even though most of our research has
happened in that particular area we know
from this result that there actually
exists a huge wealth of very interesting
architectures beyond that
and i think one of the potentially like
earliest examples that have demonstrated
that there exists this wealth of space
is actually one of
jean bruno's
earlier papers on the graph fourier
transform that you know analyzing from a
pure signal processing angle they have
shown that
you can represent basically every proper
graph convolution as just uh you know
parameterizing its
eigenvalues with respect to the
eigenvectors of the graph laplacian so
but the big issue that kind of limits us
from going further in this direction
right now is the issue that michael
highlighted of geometric stability so
basically a lot of these additional
graph neural networks that do something
more interesting than one hop spatial
message passing
pay the price in being very
geometrically unstable so the graph
fourier transform in its most generic
form will have every single
note in the graph be updated based on
whatever is located in any other node in
the graph very conditional on the graph
topology so if you imagine any kind of
approximate symmetry any kind of
perturbation either in the node features
or the edge structure of the graph
this
you basically don't have any protection
against that like that error is going to
immediately propagate everywhere and as
a result you'll end up with a
layer that theoretically works really
well but in practice is very unstable to
these kinds of numerical or inaccuracy
issues one thing that's also very
important to note is that often in graph
neural networks we have this subtle
assumption of we have the graph and
we're using this graph that's given to
us but who guarantees that the graph
that's given to you is the correct one
actually very often we estimate these
graphs based on very very
weird heuristics ourselves so
basically all of these kinds of
perfection assumptions are what might
limit the applicability of these kinds
of layers but that being said i find it
comforting that these layers exist which
means that there are meaningful ways to
push our research forward to potentially
discover new you know wonderful basins
of geometric stability inside these
different you know layers that may not
just do one hop message passing so
that's my take on this like it gives me
it gives me faith that there's more
interesting things to be discovered that
being said it is pretty tricky to find
stable layers in that
vast landscape um yeah michael do you
have some thoughts on this as well i
know you've worked quite a bit on these
geometric stability aspects
i just wanted to add one one thought
about it that
essentially locality is a feature not a
bug in many situations
and in convolutional neural networks
actually if you look uh again
historically
in the early architectures like alexnet
they started with very large filters and
the few layers were relatively few
layers i think something like five or
six and nowadays what you see is very
small filters and hundreds of layers one
of the reasons why you can do it is
because of compositionality properties
so you can you can create complex
features from from simple primitives
so in some other cases like like
manifolds there are deeper geometric
considerations why you must be local so
related to what is called the
injectivity radius of the manifold on
graphs well maybe we like a little bit
the
theoretical
necessity to be local besides of course
the computational complexity but
in many cases it is actually a good
property because
many problems do not really depend on
distant interactions so if you think of
social networks
probably most of the information comes
from your immediate neighbors is there
some sort of let's assume i
you know i have a graph
and i have my my symmetries um
my groups that i
i suspect there are in the problem or i
want to be invariant to is there
like
can you give us a bit of a practical
blueprint of how would i build a network
that
you know
takes this as an input and applies this
how would you go about this you know
what would be the building blocks that
you choose the orders and so on is there
overarching principles in how to do
i don't think that there is really a
general recipe so it's problem dependent
but maybe one example
is applications in chemistry
the basic structure that we have in
graph is permutation in variance this
has to do with the structure of the
graph itself it says nothing about the
structure of the features you might also
have some secondary
symmetry structure in the feature space
in case of molecules for example you
might have a combination of features
some of them are geometric so it's
actually not
an abstract topological graph it's a
geometric graph a molecule is a graph
that lives in three-dimensional space
and so the features are the positional
coordinates of the nodes as well as some
chemical properties such as atomic
numbers now when you deal with the
molecule you usually don't care about
how it is positioned in space you want
to be equivalent to rigid
transformations
and therefore you need to treat
accordingly the geometric coordinates of
the nodes of this graph and this is
actually what has been successfully done
so when you do
for example virtual drug screening
architectures that do message passing
but in a way that is equivalent to these
rigid transformations actually are more
successful than than generic graph
neural networks also this principle was
exploited in the recent version of alpha
fold
where they i think they call it point
environment attention which is
essentially a form of
a latent graph
neural network or a transformer
architecture with equivalent message
passing yeah i'd like i just like to add
one more point to this to this
conversation which is maybe a bit more
philosophical but it relates to you know
this aspect of building the
overarching symmetry discovering
procedures which i think would be a
really fantastic thing to have in
general and you know i hope that
some component of
a true agi is going to be
figuring out like making sense of the
data you're receiving and figuring out
what's the right kind of um what's the
right kind of symmetry to bake into it
i don't necessarily have a good opinion
on what this model might look like
but what i do say is
just looking at the immediate utility of
the geometric deep learning blueprint
we are like i think very strictly saying
that we don't want to use this blueprint
to propose
you know the one true architecture
rather we we make the argument that
different problems require different
specifications and we provide a common
language that will allow say someone who
works on primarily grid data to speak
with someone who works on manifold data
without necessarily thinking that you
know
you know common somebody might say
convenience are the ultimate
architecture someone else might say gnns
are the ultimate architecture and in
some ways
they could both be right and they could
both be wrong
but this blueprint kind of just provides
a clear delimiting
aspect to to these things just like
in the 1800s you had all these different
types of geometries that basically lived
on completely different
kinds of
geometric objects right so hyperbolic
elliptic and so on and so forth and what
kleinzerlangen program allowed us to do
was among other things
reason about all of these geometries
using the same language of group
invariants and symmetries right but in
principle
the specifics of whether you want to use
a hyperbolic uh geometry or whether you
want to use an elliptic geometry partly
rests on your assumption what the main
do you actually live in right when you
when you're doing these computations so
i think just generally speaking i think
that having a divide is a potentially
useful thing as long as you have a
language that you can use to index into
this divide if that makes sense
it does make sense but i have a feeling
that some people um could benefit from
geometric deep learning and they're
unawares i mean um because i don't want
you guys to motivate geometric deep
learning in general because i think you
know a lot of deep learning with a
structured prior is already geometric
deep learning as you folks demonstrated
in your blueprint you know like rnns and
cnn for example so you know like it or
not we're already all using geometric
deep learning but some of the esoteric
flavors of geometric deep learning
particularly on irregular meshes they
seem a little bit out there don't they i
mean it's it's possible that many people
could benefit from this but they just
don't know about it yet i was thinking
that for example if i had a lidar
scanner on my phone and the result is a
point cloud which is not particularly
useful but i would presumably transform
it into a mesh which would be more
useful but is it possible that loads of
data scientists out there are sitting on
data sets that they could be thinking
about geometrically but they're not
manifolds are exotic it's probably in
the eyes of the beholder and well in
machine learning probably they are to
some extent exotic but but
joking apart manifolds are a convenient
model for all sorts of data
and uh the data might be dimensional but
still have a low intrinsic
dimensionality or can be explained by a
small number of parameters or degrees of
freedom and this is really the premise
of
non-linear dimensionality reduction and
for example the reasons
why data visualization techniques such
as tsne at all work and maybe the key
question
as you're asking is how much of the
manifold structure of the continuous
manifold you actually leverage and in
the tsne example
the only structure that you really use
is local distances
so if you think of a point cloud
of course you can deal with it as a set
but if you assume that it comes from
sampling of some continuous surface you
can probably say more then this is for
example what we tried to do in some of
our works on geometric deep learning in
applications in computer vision and
graphics and measures are
one way of thinking of them is as graphs
and stereotypes where we have additional
structure to leverage so it's not only
nodes and edges but also faces and in
fact measures are what is called
simplicial complexes
as to the practical usefulness
computer vision and graphics are
obviously the two fields where
geometrically depending on meshes is
important and just to give a recent
example of a commercial success um
there was a british startup called the
ai it was founded by my colleague and
friend yasonas kokonos i was also one of
the investors and we had a collaboration
on 3d hand reconstruction using
geometric neural networks and the
company was acquired last year by snap
and this technology is already now part
of snap products so you see it in the
form of some
3d avatars or
virtual and augmented reality
applications that snap is developed
yeah professor bronstein i saw that you
were doing some really cool stuff with
the higher order simplicial coverings
and graphs and actually i was going to
call out your recent work on diffusion
operators and graph rewiring that there
are so many cool things that we that we
can do to graphs to actually enable a
lot of this um analysis but
there was a question from my good friend
zach jost who's one of our staff members
here and he says what do you think is
the most important problem to solve with
message passing graph neural networks
and what's the most promising path
forward probably we first need to agree
about terminology and to me message
passing and here i agree
with better is just a very generic
mechanism for
propagating information on the graph now
traditional message passing that is used
in graph neural networks uses the input
graph for this propagation and we know
right as we discussed that it is
equivalent to a device for a lemon
graphisomorphism test that has
limitations in the kinds of structures
it can detect
now there exists topological
constructions that go beyond graphs such
as simplicial and cell complexes that
you mentioned and what we did in our
recent works is developing a message
passing mechanism that
is able to work on such structures
and of course you may ask whether we do
encounter such structures in real life
so first of all we we do the meshes that
i mentioned before are in fact
simplicial complexes but secondly what
we show in the paper is that we can take
a traditional graph and lift it into a
cell or simplify complex and probably a
good example here is from the domain of
computational chemistry the graph neural
network
that you apply to a molecular graph
would consider a molecule just as a
collection of nodes and edges atoms and
chemical bonds between them but this is
not how chemists think of molecules they
think of them as structures such as for
example aromatic rings
and with our approach we can regard
rings as cells so we have a special new
object and we can do a different form of
message passing on them and we can also
show from the theoretical perspective
that
this kind of message passing is strictly
more powerful than the device for a
lemon algorithm
do you see
entirely new
problems opening up that we wouldn't
even have let's say we wouldn't even
have dared to touch before
you know in let's say
we simply have our classic neural
networks or whatnot or even our classic
graph message passing algorithms do you
see new problems that are now in reach
that previously with none of these
methods were really
let's say better than random guessing
it's a very interesting question that i
think i'll answer from from two angles
because you could like there could be
like some long-standing problem that you
knew about and wouldn't dare to attack
and now maybe you feel a bit more
confident to attack it
there's also the aspect of uncovering a
problem because when you start thinking
about things in this particular way you
might realize hang on to make this work
i made some assumptions and those
assumptions actually don't really hold
at all in principle so how do i make
things you know a little bit better so
i'll try to give an example for both of
those so in terms of a problem that
previously i don't think was very easy
to attack and now we might have some
tools that could help us attack it
better
i have a long-standing uh interest in
reinforcement learning actually when i
started my phd i spent six months
attacking a reinforcement learning
problem with one super tiny gpu and that
was at that time a massive time sink
actually deepmind ended up scooping my
work sometime after that and i quickly
moved to things that were more you know
doable with the kind of hardware that i
had at the time
but you know i always had a big interest
in this area and after joining deepmind
i started to contribute to these kinds
of directions more and more
and
i think that
basically the
there are a lot of problems in
reinforcement learning
concerning data efficiency so
when you have to learn how to
meaningfully act and do stuff which is
actually a fairly like low dimensional
signal compared to the potential
richness of the trajectories that you
have to go through before you get that
useful signal like long-term credit
assignment all these kinds of problems
i feel like we can start to get
more data efficient reinforcement
learning architectures
by leveraging geometric concepts and
also algorithmic concepts so to give you
one example of this we have
some months ago put out a paper on the
archive called the executed latent value
iteration network or excelvin
where we have
captured the essence of an algorithm in
rl which perfectly solves the rl problem
so the value iteration algorithm
assuming you give it a markov decision
process will give you the perfect policy
for that markov decision process so it's
a super attractive algorithm to think
about when you do rl
big caveat right you need to know all
the dynamics about your environment and
you need to know all the reward models
of the environment before you can apply
the algorithm so this obviously limits
its use in the more generic deep
reinforcement learning setting
but now with the knowledge of
the underlying geometry of the graph of
states that the mdp induces and the
algorithmic reasoning blueprint we
actually taught the graph neural network
which aligns super well with value
iteration actually we taught it to
in a nicely extrapolating in a
reasonably extrapolating way
on a bunch of randomly sampled mdps
learn the essence of the value iteration
computation and then we stitched it into
a planning algorithm in a deep
reinforcement learning setting and just
by
like training this pipeline end-to-end
with a model free loss we were able to
get interesting returns in atari games
much sooner than some of the competing
approaches so it's a very small step it
still requires you know hundred thousand
two hundred thousand iterations of uh
playing before you get meaning some
meaningful behaviors start to come out
but
it's a sign that we might be able to
move the needle a bit backwards and not
require you know billions and billions
of transitions before we start to see
meaningful behavior emerge and i think
that's very important because in most
real world applications of reinforcement
learning you don't have a budget for
billions of interactions
before you have to already learn a
meaningful policy so that's one side i
think and just generally in
reinforcement learning graphs appear
left right and center
not just in the algorithms but also in
the structure of the environment and
these kinds of things so i think that's
one area where geometric deep learning
could really help us
you know get better behaviors faster not
necessarily solve it better than the
standard dprl but you know get the
better behaviors and fewer interactions
and as for one problem that we have
uncovered through this kind of
observational lens
you know as i said often in graph
representation learning we assume
innocently that the graph is given to us
whereas very often this is not the case
so this
divide has brought about this new
emerging area of latent graph learning
or latent graph inference where the
objective is to learn the graph
simultaneously with using it for your
underlying decision problem and this is
a big issue for neural network
optimization because you're
fundamentally making a discrete decision
in there and if the number of nodes is
huge you cannot afford to start with the
n squared approach and then gradually
refine it so
currently the state of the art in many
regards of what we have here is to do a
k nearest neighbor graph in the feature
space and just hope that that gets us
most of the way there and usually this
works quite well for getting you know
interesting answers because you know if
you have a decent dish enough k n graph
you will cover everything that you need
reasonably quickly
but you know then there that raises the
issue of what if the graph itself is a
meaningful output of your problem what
if you're a causality researcher that
wants to figure out how different you
know parts of information interact to
them they probably wouldn't be satisfied
with a k nearest neighbor graph as an
output of this system so yeah i feel
like there's a lot of work to be done to
actually scalably and usefully do
something like this
and i i don't have a better answer than
than what i just said in state of the
art so a potential open problem for
everybody in the audience today
absolutely you touched on some really
interesting things that i think
causality is a huge area and that we
could be looking at graphs on and also
we had dr tom zahavi from deepmind one
of your colleagues and and he said that
you know he looks at metal learning and
also diversity preservation in in
agent-based learning but he thinks that
reinforcement learning is just about to
have its image in it moment where we can
discover a lot of the structure in these
problems which is fascinating
i would like to bring up
one application where maybe a
quantitative improvement that is
afforded by germanic deep running can uh
lead to a qualitative breakthrough and
this is probably of
structural biology alpha fault is one
such example for
correctly geometrically modeling
the problem you get a breakthrough in
the performance so it's indeed an
imagenet moment that happened in this
field and now once you have uh
sufficiently accurate uh prediction of
3d structure of proteins it suddenly
enables a lot of interesting
applications for example in the field of
drug design so potentially entire
pharmaceutical pipelines we invented
with the use of this technology and the
impact can be extraordinary
it's so true i mean and professor
bronson when i was watching your lecture
series it blew me away when you were
talking about all of the applications i
think yannick said a minute ago that um
it's almost as if some of these
applications are just so
ambitious that the thought wouldn't even
have crossed our mind that we might be
able to do it before like for example
being able to predict facial geometry
from a dna sequence so we might be able
to look at an old dna sequence and
actually see what that person looked
like that would have been unimaginable
just a few years ago so that that's
incredible i i'm really interested in
your definition of intelligence right
and whether you think neural networks
could ever be intelligent um douglas
hofstadter for example he wrote the
famous book godel escherbach it was a
pulsier
prize winning book in the 1970s but he
made the argument that analogy is the
core of cognition he said that analogies
are a bit like the interstate freeway of
cognition they're not little modules on
the side or something like that and i
think that in a way analogies are also
symmetries right so when i say that
someone is firewalling a person
it means that they don't want to talk
with that person it's a symmetry between
the abstract representation of a real
network firewall and an abstract social
category so does this require a
different neural network architecture or
could geometric deep learning already
deliver the goods right it's almost as
if it's just a representation problem i
think it's a very important question one
which
well i i cannot claim to have the right
answer to and my definition is i guess a
little bit skewed by
the the specific research that i do and
the engineering approaches that i do but
i think in large i agree with the idea
of analogy making and maybe i would take
it a step further right where you have a
particular set of knowledge and
conclusions that you've derived so far
a set of primitives that you can use
once new information comes in to figure
out how to recompose them and either
discover new analogies or just discover
new conclusions that you can use in the
next
step of reasoning
and
you know it it just feels really
amenable to a kind of synergy of as
daniel kahneman puts it system one and
system two right you have the perceptive
component that feeds in the raw
information that you receive as your
input data
transforms it into some kind of abstract
conceptual information and then in the
system two land you have access to this
kind of
reasoning procedures that are able to
take all these concepts and derive new
ones from
hopefully a nice and not very high
dimensional set of rules
and
this is why i believe that if we that in
terms of like moving towards
the an architecture that supports
something like this i think we have a
lot of the building blocks in place with
geometric deep learning especially if
we're willing to as i said kind of
broaden the definition of geometric deep
learning to also include category theory
concepts because that might allow us to
reconcile algorithmic computation as
well into the blueprint so the idea is
you know you have this i mean there's no
need to talk at length about all these
great perceptive architectures so i
think we're already at a point of if we
show our agi lots and lots of data it's
going to be able to pick up on a lot of
the interesting things just by observing
like you know self-supervised learning
unsupervised learning is already showing
a lot of promise there
but then the question is where i think
we still have quite a bit of work to do
is once we have these concepts let's
even assume that they're perfect what do
we do with them how do we meaningfully
use them and i think the reason why i
believe there's a lot of work to be done
there is because one of the
very key things that i do on a
day-to-day basis is teach graph neural
networks to imitate algorithms from
perfect data so i give them exactly the
abstract input that the algorithm would
expect and i asked them hey simulate
this algorithm for me please
and it turns out that
that is super super hard well it's super
easy to do it in distribution but you're
not algorithmic if you don't extrapolate
and that's i think one of the big
challenges that we need to work towards
addressing will geometric deep learning
be enough to encompass the ultimate
solution
i have a feeling that it will
but
you know i don't i don't necessarily
just based on the empirical evidence
we've been seeing in the recent papers
that we've put out but
yeah i don't i don't have a very strong
theoretical reason why i think it's
going to be enough
yeah
i'm fascinated by this notion that
intelligence isn't mysterious as we
might think it is it's a it's a receding
horizon and it might in the end be
disappointingly simple to mechanize
actually if you take the term literally
intelligence come from the latent world
that means to understand
and i think what is meant by
understanding is really a very vague
question and probably if you ask
different people they will give you
different definitions
i would define it as the faculty to
abstract information
and in particular information that is
obtained in one context the ability to
use it in in other contexts this is what
we usually call learning the way that
this information is abstracted and
represented might be very different in a
biological neural network in our brain
versus an artificial intelligence system
so
if you
hear some people saying that that
the brain probably doesn't really
do
geometric computations
my answer to that would be that we don't
necessarily need to imitate exactly the
way that the brain works
we just need probably to try to achieve
this high level mechanism that is able
to abstract information and applied as
knowledge to different problems the
definitions of artificial intelligence
that are being used like the famous
turing test i find is very disturbing
that it's very
anthropocentric and
it is actually probably very
characteristic of the human species more
broadly and
this way by judging
what is intelligent and what is not we
might potentially rule out other
intelligent species because they they're
very different from us i may be obsessed
with sperm whales because i'm working on
studying their communication
they are definitely intelligent
creatures but would they pass the turing
test
probably not it's like subjecting
a cat to a swimming test or
a fish tote or climbing on a tree
so
i would just like to add to michael's
great answer
one quote that i think is is very
popular and like applies really well in
this setting the question of whether
computers to think can think is about as
relevant as whether submarines can swim
when you built submarines you weren't
necessarily trying to copy fish you were
solving a problem that was fundamentally
slightly different
so
could be relevant in this case as well
we we spend quite a lot of time on this
podcast talking about you know whether
we should have an anthropocentric
conception of intelligence so you know a
corporation is intelligent right and
i'm starting to come around to the view
of embodiment and and thinking that
there is something very um human-like
about our particular flavor of
intelligence but maybe there is a kind
of pure intelligence as well and this
was the end of my conversation with taco
cohen one of the really interesting
things is you're getting on to um
some of the work that you've done are
being able to think of group
convolutions on um
homogeneous objects like spheres for
example but also you moved on to
irregular objects like any mesh and you
looked into things like fiber bundles
and and and local and convolution
because these are objects i think you
said a homogeneous object is where you
can't perform some transformation to get
from one place of the object to the
other part of the object so what work
did you do there on those irregular
objects
yeah that's a that's a great question so
you know when we think of convolution
we're sort of putting together a whole
bunch of things uh namely this idea of
locality so typically our filters are
local but that is um
that's a choice ultimately convolution
doesn't have to use a local filter
although in practice we know that works
very well
and there's the idea of weight sharing
between different positions and
potentially also between different
orientations of the filter
and um
as i mentioned uh before the this this
weight sharing really comes from the
symmetry um so
the fact that you use the same filter at
each position in your image when you're
doing a two-dimensional convolution
that's because you want to try to to
respect the translation
symmetry acting on the on the plane
um in the case of a general manifold or
or mesh
you typically not have a global symmetry
uh if you think of a mesh representing a
human figure or let's say it's some
complicated protein structure
uh there may not be a global symmetry
or sometimes in the case of say a
molecule might have some six-fold
rotational symmetry this symmetry may
not be
transitive as it's called meaning you
cannot take any two points on your
manifold and map one to the other using
a symmetry in the case of a sphere you
can do that any two points in the sphere
are related by rotation so we say a
sphere is a homogeneous space
but this let's say this uh protein uh
shape is not homogeneous even if it has
some some kind of symmetry
um so in that case if you try to
motivate the weight sharing via symmetry
you try to take your filter put it in
one position move it around to a
different position using the symmetry
you're not going to be able to hit all
positions so you're not going to get
weight sharing
globally
and
you know that just is what it is if you
say i have a signal on this manifold
uh and i want uh
uh to respect the symmetries well if
there are no global symmetries there's
nothing to respect so you get no
constraints you can just use
arbitrary linear map
now it turns out there are certain
other kinds of symmetries called gauge
symmetries that you might still want to
respect
and
in practice
what respecting gauge symmetry
will do is will put some constraints on
the filter
at a particular position
so for example that might have to be a
rotationally aquivariant filter
but it doesn't tie the weights of
filters at different positions
um so if you want that as well then
you can
maybe motivate it via some kind of
notion of local symmetry i have
something on a local symmetry groupoid
to motivate that in my in my thesis
uh but
uh
there isn't uh there isn't uh
a very principled way to to motivate
weight sharing on general manifolds
actually between different locations
yeah i'm just trying to get my head
around this so so you're saying because
the whole point of that we're trying to
achieve here is to
have a parameter efficient neural
network you know that uses local
connectivity and weight sharing as we do
with let's say a planar cnn whereas when
you have an irregular object it's very
very difficult to do that so you're
saying in some restricted domain you can
do it let's say if you have a
let's say rotation equivalence but you
can't do the other forms of of weight
sharing
i'm just trying to get my head around
this because um with a graph convolution
on your network for example it seems
like you can abstract the local
neighborhood this node is connected to
these other nodes and potentially that
could translate to a different part of
the irregular mesh so
why can't you do it
more than than you suggested
i think if you want to be precise you
just have to say what are the symmetries
that we're talking about here
and
in a graph the most obvious one is the
global permutation symmetry so you can
reorder the nodes of a graph
and really any graph neural net whether
they're taught they're coming from an
equivariance perspective or not all
graphical nets in existence that uh that
have been proposed they they respect
this permutation symmetry
and typically this happens through let's
say in in the most simple kind of uh
graph convolutional nets like the ones
by uh kit fan welding for example
there's a sum operation some messages
from your neighbors and some operation
does depend on the order
of the summons so it doesn't depend on
the order of the neighbors and that's
why the whole thing becomes equivalent
uh so so that's a global symmetry that
that all graph networks uh respect on
that though could you not create a local
let's say if there was a local graph
isomorphism and so i have an irregular
object but it has a local isomorphism
could i not use something like a gcn a
local version of it to capture that
isomorphism
yeah
uh so actually this was uh something we
we proposed to do in our paper natural
graph networks so this paper really has
two aspects
to it one is the naturality as a
generalization of equivariance i can
talk about that
uh but
another key point was that we can not
just develop a global natural graph
network as we call it but also a local
one and what the local one will do
is it will look at uh certain
local motifs so maybe
uh if you're analyzing molecular graphs
one motif that you often find is uh
you know aromatic ring or something some
some ring with let's say six uh
corners
various other kinds of little small
grass motifs
um and these motifs might appear
multiple times in the same molecule or
across different molecules and so what
the this method is doing is it's
essentially finding those using some
kind of graph isomorph local graph
isomorphism uh uh
and then making sure that whenever we
encounter this particular motif
uh we process it in the same way uh with
ie using the same weights and if the
local motif has some kind of symmetry
like this this aromatic ring you can
rotate it six times and it gets back to
the origin or you can flip it over
so that's the symmetry of this graph
structure or an automorphism of this
graph and then the weights will also be
constrained by this automorphism group
this group of symmetries of the local
motif
uh and various other other authors also
have i think even um uh michael
bronstein and students have have
developed
methods based on on similar uh similar
ideas
awesome taco it's been such an honor
having you on the show and actually
you're coming back on the show in a few
weeks time so we don't want to spoil the
surprise but um looking on this proto
book that you've written with the other
folks what's the what's the main thing
that sticks out to you as being like the
coolest thing in the book
i think uh there's any one particular
thing uh what excites me uh is
uh to put some order to the chaos uh of
the the the zoo of of architectures and
to see actually that there is uh
something that they all have in common
um and i i really think this can help uh
you know new people who are new to the
field to to learn more quickly
uh to get an overview of of all the
things that are out there
um and uh i also think that uh this is
the start
of what at least one way in which we can
take the black box of deep learning
which uh often is is is viewed as
completely inscrutable and actually
start to open it and start to understand
uh how the pieces connect
uh which can then perhaps inform future
developments uh that are uh
guided by both empirical results and an
understanding of what's going on
amazing thanks so much taco
thanks for having me it's been a
pleasure
juwan thank you so much for joining us
this has been amazing okay no thank you
so much tim it was a very fun and uh uh
best of luck and uh i think um let's
maybe get in touch vintage thank you
very much
it's very nice to be talking to you
today about these completely random
topics